को प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस प्लीज लेट मी
नो ओके
सो सो मुझे जल्दी से आप सभी बता दीजिए कि
ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है एवरीथिंग इज
फाइन
गाइस प्लीज लेट मी नो ओके सो जल्दी से
बताइए मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ क्लियर
एवरीथिंग इ एब्सलूट
फाइन ओके लेट मी सी द चैट्स चलिए तो यहां
पर चलो आ रहे हैं सभी
लोग ओके आ जाइए जल्दी आ जाइए एवरीथिंग इ
गुड ओके ग्रेट गुड इवनिंग
सबको सभी को गुड गुड इवनिंग एंड वेलकम टू
द डे फोर ऑफ बग बांटी फ्री कोर्स फ्री
क्लासेस वेलकम एवरी बडी
ओके चलिए तो सबको आने देते हैं एक बार
थोड़ी देर में सभी आ जाएंगे जैसे ही
नोटिफिकेशन जाएगी सबको एवरीवन विल जॉइन द
सेशन
ओके
चलिए
बढ़िया ओके चलिए तो आज हम डे फोर आज का जो
क्लास है वो डे फोर क्लास है हमारा बग
बाउंट का एंड आज का क्लास जो है ना मतलब
का काफी ज्यादा बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
होने वाला है ठीक है बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट होगा एंड काफी कुछ सीखने वाले
हैं जानने वाले हैं फुल ऑन प्रैक्टिकल
करने वाले हैं आज के क्लास में आज की
क्लास को मिस मत करना एंड देखो बग बाउंट
जो मैं आपको सिखा रहा हूं एज अ बिगनर मैं
कंसीडर कर रहा हूं यू आर एब्सलूट बिगनर
एंड एज अ बिगनर आपको स्टेप वाइज चलना है
अगर आप स्टेप वाइज नहीं चलोगे बाद में जब
हम लाइव टारगेट को अ अ लाइफ टारगेट को चूज
करके एंड उन पे हम जब उनको जब हम टारगेट
करेंगे पन टेस्ट टेस्टिंग करेंगे उन पे
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करेंगे उन पे एंड उन
पे बग्स फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे तो आप
वहां पे पीछे रह जाओगे आप नहीं कर पाओगे
क्यों क्योंकि आपने बेसिक जो है ना जो
पहले के स्टेप्स है उनको कंप्लीट नहीं करा
है एंड इन्हीं स्टेप्स में से एक सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है वो है बब सूट का
नॉलेज रखना बब सूट इज अ वेरी वेरी वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप इन योर बग बाउंट जर्नी
एंड अगर आपने इसको स्किप किया सिंसियर
नहीं इसको समझा तो फिर आपका ये जो बग
बाउंट जर्नी है वो अधूरा माना जाएगा यह
एकदम से ुत मतलब यूनिवर्सल ट्रुथ है इसको
आप मान के रखो ठीक है अब मेरे से आप सब
मुझे बताओ सबको सबसे पहले तो गुड इवनिंग
एंड वेलकम टू द डे फोर एंड मैं हूं नितेश
सिंह फाउंडर ऑफ सी फाउंडर एंड सीईओ
डिफ्रॉक साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट
लिमिटेड एंड आई एम कंटिन्यूइंग योर दिस ब
बक बाउटी जर्नी तो मुझे आप सबसे पहले
बताइए कि आप में से कितने लोगों को बॉब
शूट का नॉलेज है बिगनर इंटरमीडिएट एंड
एक्सपर्ट लेवल आप अपने लेवल के अकॉर्डिंग
मुझे चैट में बताइए कि व्हाट लेवल यू हैव
रिगार्डिंग द बर्ब शूट नॉलेज ठीक है
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल के हो बिगनर लेवल के हो
या एक्सपर्ट लेवल की नॉलेज रखते हो बब शूट
के अंदर में लेट मी नो इन द चैट बॉक्स एंड
आई एम रीडिंग योर चैट्स राइट
नाउ
ओके लेट मी सी सबको नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग अभय
गौरव नशिक फैक्ट नंबर
वन रेन रॉकी राजीव
संतोष मेहदी हसन रोहन समम ब्लॉग सबको सबको
सबके नाम नहीं ले सकता तो जिनके छूट गया
हो प्लीज डोंट मा ओके चलिए बिगनर
इंटरमीडिएट बिगनर जीरो पर बिगनर
इंटरमीडिएट लिट बट बिगनर बिगनर
[संगीत]
बिगनर ठीक है इंटरमीडिएट बिगनर
सर इतना नॉलेज है कि कॉलेज की वेबसाइट के
लॉगइन पोर्टल पर ओटीपी बायपास कर लेते हैं
क्या बात है बहुत
बढ़िया चलिए इंटरमीडिएट बिगनर चलिए काफी
लोगों का बिगनर आंसर है कुछ लोगों के
इंटरमीडिएट भी है एंड एंड बहुत ही रेयर है
ऐसा कुछ कि जिन्होंने एक्सपर्ट लिखा हो
एक्सपर्ट शायद कोई यहां पर अभी है नहीं
एक्सपर्ट बोलना भी सही नहीं है ठीक है ना
तो नोबडी कैन बी बिकम एन एक्सपर्ट राइट अब
आप जल्दी से इस लाइव स्ट्रीम को ना शेयर
कर दो अपने दोस्तों के बीच जल्दी से कि आज
की डे फॉर क्लास स्ट्रीम हो रही है फटाफट
कर दो ठीक है चलिए तो आज जो हम क्लास में
करेंगे वो आपको बर्ब सूट के इंटरमीडिएट
लेवल तक लेके जाएगा एकदम से लेके जाएगा
बिगनर से इंटरमीडिएट लेकर जाएगा एंड आपको
बब शूट की नॉलेज नहीं है तो आपको बग बाउंट
करने में आपको मजा नहीं आएगा आप बहुत कुछ
कर ही नहीं पाओगे इनफैक्ट अगर आपको बब शूट
की नॉलेज नहीं है या किसी भी प्रॉक्सी टूल
जैसे ओ जैप है लगभग आप बब शूट यूज करना
सीख जाओगे समझ जाओगे तो आप उसको भी यूज कर
लोगे कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है तो आपको मतलब
आधी से ज्यादा तो नॉलेज वैसे भी नहीं है
और आप आगे इंक्रीज अपने आप अपनी स्किल्स
को इंक्रीज नहीं कर पाओगे आप आगे बढ़ नहीं
पाओगे ठीक है तो बब शट जाना बहुत ज्यादा
जरूरी है मुझे जल्दी मुझे इतना बता दज
जल्दी से हां हां हां लाइक भी करना है यह
सही याद
दिलाया यह सही याद
दिलाया लाइक भी करना है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
चलो धन्यवाद आप लोगों ने प्रीवियस वीडियो
को तो वीडियो प तो मचा दिया था अच्छी खासी
लाइक और व्यूज वगैरह सब आए इस पे भी
उम्मीद यही करते हैं हम एंड मुझे बता
दीजिए अब तक जो आपने तीन क्लासेस जो
प्रीवियस अटेंड करे हैं आप में से
मैक्सिमम लोगों ने अटेंड करे होंगे मुझे
पता है क्योंकि जितने लोग प्रीवियस सेशंस
में आ रहे थे वो ऑलमोस्ट मैक्सिमम लोग ना
लाइव में रहते हैं एंड ये सबसे अच्छी बात
है मेरे मोटिवेशन के लिए मेरी क्वालिटी ऑफ
ट्रेनिंग के लिए सबके लिए और आपके लिए
आपकी लर्निंग के लिए मुझे बता दीजिए पहली
तीन क्लासेस आपको कैसी लगी है एकदम से
ऑनेस्ट बताइएगा नेस्ट नेली बताइएगा कैसे
लगे हैं एंड इसी फ्लो में चलता रहना चाहिए
ना चलिए तो आज के सेशन में हम बब शूट के
इंस्टॉलेशन को इन डेप्थ समझेंगे
इंस्टॉलेशन को समझना का मतलब है ना
इंस्टॉलेशन में आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
आनी चाहिए बबस के टैब्स के बारे में
जानेंगे बब शूट को पूरा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे
एकदम एकदम पूरा कि आपको थोड़ा भी समझ ना
आए ना वो समझ में आ जाएगा बब के एक फीचर
के बारे में बात करेंगे बहुत शानदार फीचर
के बारे में एंड इन सब की प्रैक्टिकल तो
खैर हमारी चलती ही रहेगी ठीक है चलो
बढ़िया थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू वेरी मच
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
अ बहुत बढ़िया थैंक यू चलिए तो आज जो है
सबसे पहले आप सब में से कितने लोगों ने बब
शूट वाली फाइल जो है ना जिप फाइल डाउनलोड
कर ली है मैंने जो ऐप से बताया था आपको बब
शूट की जिप फाइल डाउनलोड करनी थी कितने
लोगों ने डाउनलोड कर लिया है जल्दी बताइए
मुझे एकदम सच सच बताना झूठ मत बोलना जो
मैंने आपको बताया था ना कि बॉब शूट की
फाइल डाउनलोड करनी है कितने लोगों ने कर
लिया भाई कहां से डाउनलोड करना था जिप
फाइल 1.7 एक वर्जन के लिए मैंने बोला था
उसके पीछे कुछ स्पेसिफिक रीजन इसलिए मैंने
आपको पर्टिकुलर वर्ब सूट का वर्जन डाउनलोड
करने को बोला था हमारे नस एडमी ए
एप्लीकेशन से आपको न एडमी ए एप्लीकेशन को
ओपन करना था आपको जो हमारा फ्री कोर्स था
उसमें जाना था एंड वहां से डाउनलोड कर
लेना था आपको जिफ फाइल उसी जिफ फाइल के
अंदर ही आपकी सारी जो भी अ जो सॉफ्टवेयर
रिक्वायरमेंट है बॉब शूट के लिए वो आपको
वहां पे मिल जाती ठीक है तो आपको सिंपली
ऐप खोल के उसमें जाके और डाउनलोड कर लीजिए
ठीक है यहां पे पप में ऐप ओपन होने में
थोड़ा टाइम लग रहा है आई थिंक तो कोई कोई
बात नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ये आप
कर लीजिएगा अगर आपने नहीं किया होगा तो आप
हमारे ऐप पे जाइएगा हमारे जो कोर्स पेज है
उस परे जाइएगा एंड वहां पे आपको फ्री
कोर्स जो मिलेगा वहां से आप फ्री
रिसोर्सेस वाले में जाके बब शूट को
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं अभी फिलहाल हमारा ऐप
जो है वो शायद मे भी सही से काम नहीं कर
रहा है एंड कुछ प्रॉब्लम है राइट कुछ देयर
इज सम इश्यूज हियर
दैट्ची
ओके ओके चलिए आ गया वर्क कर रहा है इस
वाले कोर्स में चले जाइएगा यहां पे कंटेंट
में जाइएगा यहां बग बाउंट नहीं फ्री
रिसोर्सेस में जाइएगा यहां बब शूट मिलेगा
आपको इसको डाउनलोड करना था क्योंकि यहां
से हम इसी को यूज करने वाले हैं अब मैं
आपको ना पूरी एगजैक्टली
ऐप डाउन है हां ऐप में थोड़ी अभी इशू है
थोड़ा सा डाउन टाइम है अभी तो अभी थोड़ा
सा प्रॉब्लम आ रहा है ऐप को ओपन करने में
एंड ऐप को एक्सप्लोर करने में थोड़ी देर
में वो सही हो जाएगा तो फिर आपको वहां पे
बब शूट जो है वो मिल जाएगी यहीं पे मिलेगी
आपको इसी के अंदर में ठीक है ये जो
पर्टिकुलर फोल्डर आपको इसके अंदर कंटेंट
है ना इस कोर्स के अंदर में इसके अंदर मिल
जाएगी
चलिए अब यहां बात कर लेते हैं सबसे पहली
चीज कि बब शूट को आप विज में भी यूज कर
सकते हैं आप काली
सा ऑथेंटिक वे में आपको बता रहा हूं ठीक
है तो यहां पे आप डाउनलोड बब शूट
कम्युनिटी एडिशन का एक लिंक आएगा आप इस पे
जाएंगे ठीक है यहां जब आएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको सीधा डाउनलोड करने का ऑप्शन आएगा
ईमेल आईडी डालिए और डाउनलोड कर लीजिए या
तो गो स्ट्रेट टू डाउनलोड्स आप डाउनलोड्स
पे आएंगे यहां पे एंड यहां पे आपको ऑप्शन
मिलेगा कि बब शूट का कम्युनिटी एडिशन
डाउनलोड करना है कि आपको इसका प्रोफेशनल
एडिशन डाउनलोड करना है
या तो आपको नए वाले जो m1 प्रोसेसर एल
सिलिकन प्रोसेसर आर उनके लिए करना है
कोई टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है किस तरीके से
आपको उसको स्टार्ट करना है बट सबसे पहले
विज से भी पहले हम बॉब शूट के
काली ही है एज अ प्राइमरी ओस तो भी आप
इंस्टॉल स्टार्ट कीजिए आप सबके लैपटॉप में
लाइक काली होना चाहिए बस
दैट्ची यो काली आल्सो जल्दी से वूट
कीजिए साथ में कितने लोग साथ में कर रहे
हैं जरा बताइए मुझे कितने लोगों का लैपटॉप
ऑन है एंड जो मैं करता हूं वो साथ कर रहे
हैं अभी अभी आज के सेशन में कम से कम बता
दो कितने लोग साथ में कर रहे हैं मुझे
मुझे बता दो जरा और बहुत ज्यादा
प्रैक्टिकल बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट सेशन होने
वाली है आज की आज की सेशन प्लीज मिस मत
करना थोड़ा भी मिस मत करना बहुत मजा आएगा
ठीक है ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट एक पार्ट है
आपके बग बाउटी जर्नी का क्योंकि बग
बाउंटीज में हम आगे जब पेन टेस्टिंग
करेंगे जब हम आगे वल एबिलिटीज फाइंड
करेंगे तो हम बब शूट का यूज मैक्सिमम टाइम
करने वाले हैं हम बब शूट पे ही सब कुछ
करेंगे इनफैक्ट बब शूट मतलब यार ओशियन
है मतलब आपको इसमें इतने तरीके मिलेंगे ना
वोले बिटीज फाइंड करने के इतनी सारी
ऑप्शंस फीचर्स है कि यू विल बी ब्लोन अवे
बाय द फीचर्स तो हमारा यहां काली ओपन हो
चुका है लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर
यूजिंग काली और यूजिंग और डूइंग
प्रैक्टिकल अलोंग विद
मी मैंने जो दिया है आप विज में भी यूज कर
सकते हो उसको विंडोज में आपको यूज करना है
चलिए अब काली में आपको कम्युनिटी एडिशन
मिल जाती है प्रोफेशनल एडिशन नहीं मिलती
है बट आप अगर चाहे तो प्रोफेशनल एडिशन
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं उसके लिए आपको बहुत
महंगा प्रोफेशनल एडिशन खरीदना पड़ेगा या
तो कोई और तरीका आपके पास है तो आप यूज कर
सकते हैं मैं उस पर ज्यादा डिस्कशन अभी
नहीं करना चाहता हूं क्योंकि ये जो
ट्रेनिंग ये जो कोर्सेस चल रहे हैं
बिल्कुल एजुकेशनल पर्पस के लिए हम यहां पे
जो भी कर रहे हैं लीगली कर रहे हैं तो
काली में बब शूट का पैकेज है आप जब
टर्मिनल ओपन करेंगे तो आप एप्ट की
रिपोजिटरी को जब चेक करेंगे तो एप्ट लिस्ट
कमांड डालिए और यहां पे आप डालिए बब शूट
बब शूट करके एंटर कीजिएगा तो आपको एप्ट
रिपोजिटरी के अंदर से बब शूट नाम की जो
पैकेज है वो रिट्रीव होके आ जाएगी तो आपको
दिख रहा होगा कि काली रोलिंग के अंदर बब
शूट नाम की एक पैकेज है इस रिपोजिटरी में
एंड ये जो है इंस्टॉल्ड ऑटोमेटिक लिखा रहा
है यानी कि ये काली में ऑटोमेटिक यानी
इनिशियली ही इंस्टॉल्ड आता है जब
इंस्टॉल्ड लिखा रहे इसका मतलब सिर्फ
इंस्टॉल्ड अगर लिखा रहे ना इसका मतलब होता
है आपने इंस्टॉल किया है मैनुअली उस पैकेज
को अगर ऑटोमेटिक लिख के यहां पे आ गया
इसका मतलब ये प्री डिफाइंड है मतलब सॉरी
प्री इंस्टॉल्ड आया है आपके काली के साथ
तो बब शूट यहां पे इंस्टॉल्ड है चलिए अब
ये एक जीआई एप्लीकेशन है भैया तो जीआई
एप्लीकेशन के लिए यहां पे जाइए बब को सर्च
कीजिए बब शूट नाम का एक ऐसा आइकन आ जाता
है एक उस पे आपको क्लिक करके इसको ओपन कर
लेना है यहां लिखा है बॉब शूट कम्युनिटी
एडिशन देखो यहां पे यहां पे सीधा लिखा है
बॉब शूट का कम्युनिटी एडिशन यानी कि फ्री
एडिशन है यहां पे आप ओपन करेंगे इस तरह का
प्रोमट आएगा एक जावा जे आरई का प्रोमट
आएगा आप उसको हटा दीजिएगा ओके करके एंड
उसके बाद आपका ये प्रोमट आ जाएगा इसके बाद
आपको नेक्स्ट करना है एंड देख लीजिए वर्जन
कौन सा है 2020
3.10.3 6 यह वर्जन करंट वर्जन है अभी बब
शूट का इसके बाद आपको नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक
करना है उसके बाद स्टार्ट बड पे आपको
क्लिक कर देना है एंड बॉब शूट विल स्टार्ट
चलिए वेट करते
हैं बढ़िया अब यहां पे बब शूट यहां पे ओपन
होके आ चुका है अब यहां सबसे पहले काम
करते हैं यहां पर हम चलते हैं यहां पर हम
चलते हैं वेयर वेयर वेयर वेयर वेर वेर वेर
वेर वेर वेयर अ चलिए यहां पे सेटिंग्स पे
एक बार चल लेते हैं यूजर पे चल लेते हैं
एंड यर लेट्स फाइंड सम सेटिंग्स लेट्स गो
टू द ऑल एंड मैं यहां पर एक चीज देख रहा
हूं एंड लेट मी फाइंड अ सेटिंग फॉर
यू ओके यूजर इज हियर
[संगीत]
एंड ओके य सेटिंग्स पे चलते हैं यहां पे
यहां पे
एक लेट मी सी वन
थिंग ओके चलिए इसको रहने देते हैं मैं
इसको क्या कर रहा था आई वाज डूइंग समथिंग
फॉर यू यहां पे आपके लिए कुछ कर रहा था
मैं यूजर सेटिंग्स प चलते हैं एंड लोड
यूजर सेटिंग्स प चलते हैं एंड हियर हियर
इट इज चलो एक काम करते हैं यहां बब पे
चलते हैं यूजर सेटिंग्स पे यहां पे चल
देते हैं एंड यहां पर करते हैं
सर्च यहां पर फंट प आ जाते हैं राइट तो
मैं यह फंट वाली सेटिंग्स को यहां पे खोज
रहा था एंड यहां पे थोड़ा फंट को ना
इंक्रीज कर देते थोड़ा सा ये मोनोस्पेस जो
है फंट वो रहने देते हैं बट यहां प 13 से
मैं इसको कर देता हूं 16 थोड़ा सा आपको
बड़ा दिखेगा तो थोड़ा आपको अच्छा दिखेगा
ठीक है तो हमने यहां पे 16 कर दिया है
थोड़ा सा एंड अगेन वी हैव डन दिस सेटिंग
आई थिंक सो
यस ठीक है तो सेटिंग हमने कर दिया यहां
पे बाप शूट को अगेन क्लोज करके एंड
लेट्स ओपन इट चलिए तो यहां से आपने थोड़ा
सा फंट इंक्रीज कर लेना है थोड़ा बढ़िया
शायद दिखेगा थोड़ा अच्छा क्लियर दिखेगा तो
अब बब शूट को ओपन करते हैं अब हम बब शूट
में यहां पे और भी कुछ चीजें देखेंगे जो
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है अब इसके हम
कॉन्फिन की पहले देखेंगे देन हम इसके आगे
के दूसरे फीचर्स के बारे में जानेंगे एंड
समझेंगे तो चलिए बप शूट को यहां पे
स्टार्ट हो हो गया चलिए आई डोंट नो ये
इफेक्ट हुआ कि नहीं इनफेक्ट हुआ कि नहीं
हुआ यहां प्रॉक्सी पे चलके पहले प्रॉक्सी
यहां पे इंटरसेप्ट आपका ऑफ आ रहा है चलो
बहुत बढ़िया बात है अब यहां पे ये
कम्युनिटी एडिशन है अब बब का कम्युनिटी
एडिशन और प्रोफेशनल एडिशन दोनों में ना
डिफरेंस है दोनों में डिफरेंस है क्या
डिफरेंस है मैं आपको बता देता हूं जैसे
कम्युनिटी एडिशन में क्या होता है
इंगेजमेंट टूल्स आपको एक चीज होती है एक
फीचर होता है वो इंगेजमेंट टूल आपको नहीं
मिलता है बर्ब के कम्युनिटी एडिशन में
आपको बहुत सारी ऐसी फीचर्स जैसे कि जैसे
कि लाइव स्कैनिंग आपको नहीं मिलती है जैसे
आप न्यू लाइव स्कैन पे अगर आप जाते हैं तो
यहां पे आपको दिखेगा लाइव ऑडिट में कि
प्रो वर्जन के लिए है ओनली ठीक है
इंट्रूडर के कुछ फीचर्स लिमिटेड होते हैं
ट्राइम थ्रोटलिंग होती है स्पीड लिमिटेशंस
होती है यह सारी चीजें होती हैं जो प्रो
वर्जन में आपको नहीं एकदम अनलिमिटेड मिलती
है कम्युनिटी में थोड़ा सा लिमिटेशन आ
जाता है ये डिफरेंस होता है अब चलिए देखिए
मुझे पहले कॉन्फिन आपको समझा नहीं है कैसे
इसको
कॉन्फिन के साथ ठीक है तो ये दोनों चीजें
करनी है चलिए अब क्या करते हैं बब शूट को
हमने ओपन कर लिया बब शूट को ओपन करते ही
आपको इसको ब्राउजर में कंफिल करना है बब
शूट वर्क कैसे करता है मैं आपको सीधा-सीधा
बहुत ही सिंपल सा समझा देता हूं बब शूट
कैसे काम करता है बब शूट एक इंटरमीडिएट
कनेक्टिव कनेक्शंस की तरह काम करता है एक
इंटरमीडियरी की तरह काम करता है मतलब एक
तरह का वीपीएन समझ लो यार एक तरह का
प्रॉक्सी समझ लो उसकी तरह काम करता है
मतलब जो भी रिक्वेस्ट जो भी रिक्वेस्ट एक
क्लाइंट सर्वर को सेंड कर रहा है जैसे कि
मैं इसको वैसे समझाता
हूं मैं इसको ना वैसे समझाता हूं लेट यहां
पे
[संगीत]
ऑनलाइन ऑनलाइन
मार्क पैड इस तरह से इसके हम देखते
[संगीत]
हैं ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर आपको एक चीज
समझा देता हूं जैसे यह रहा मेरा क्लाइंट
है यह मेरा सर्वर है ठीक है दिस इज द
क्लाइंट एंड दिस इज द सर्वर बीच में आप
क्या यूज कर रहे हो आप यूज कर रहे हो बर्ब
को बीच में आप क्या यूज कर रहे
हो बब शूट को ठीक है आप इसको बीच में यूज
कर रहे हो अब क्लाइंट यूजुअली क्या होता
है यूजुअली व्हाट हैपेंस यूजुअली यूजुअली
क्या होता है जब आप एक रिक्वेस्ट रिप्लाई
कर रहे होते हो रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस खेल
रहे होते हो तो क्लाइंट से सर्वर के बीच
डायरेक्ट बात हो रही होती है यूजुअली मतलब
बाकी चीजें बाद में डीएनएस से ऑनस ये सब
हटा देते हैं क्लाइंट की सर्वर से
इंटरेक्शन हो रही होती है सर्वर की फिर
क्लाइंट से जैसे ये क्लाइंट ने इसको इधर
किया फिर सर्वर इसको क्या करेगा इस तरीके
से रेस्पों करेगा यही होता है बट बप जब
बीच में आ जाती है तो क्लाइंट जो
रिक्वेस्ट सेंड कर रहा है यानी कि आपका
ब्राउजर जो रिक्वेस्ट सेंड कर रहा है वो
बब के थ्रू आप उसको इंटरसेप्ट कर सकते हो
उसमें नेसेसरी चेंजेज कर सकते हो एंड उसको
फिर सर्वर को आप भेज सकते हो सर्वर से जो
रिस्पांस आ रहा है उसको आप इंटरसेप्ट कर
सकते हो उसमें नेसेसरी चेंजेज कर सकते हो
एंड देन आप क्लाइंट को भेज सकते हो अब
इससे दिमाग खुल जाएगा कि बप हाउ मच
इंपॉर्टेंट बप इज मतलब भैया ये क्लाइंट ये
सर्वर दोनों एक दूसरे से बात कर रहे हैं
बीच में आ गया बब शूट क्लाइंट के भी को
कैप्चर कर सकता है सर्वर के भी कर सकता है
रिस्पांस को एंड बीच में जो भी चेंजेज है
जो भी चीजें पढ़नी है जाननी है सीखनी है
सब ये बर्प करेगा सोचो एज अ क्लाइंट तुम
एक यूजर नेम और एक पासवर्ड लिख के भेज रहे
हो सवर को एंड वो तुम कैप्चर करके उसको
तुम पढ़ ले रहे हो बीच में तो ये तुम्हारा
बर्ब करेगा तो जितने रिक्वेस्ट हैं वो
सारे बर्ब से होके जाएंगे उसपे जो भी
प्रोसेसेस हैं जो भी स्टेप्स हैं जो भी
चीजें आप कर सकते हो फर दर प्रोसेसिंग देन
यू कैन सेंड टू द क्लाइंट सॉरी सर्वर एंड
देन अगेन सेम इन केस ऑफ सर्वर कि सर्वर ज
जो भी रिस्पांस दे रहा है क्लाइंट के तरफ
आप उसको उस तरीके से चेंज करके कर सकते हो
ठीक है
ओके बढ़िया अब समझ में आएगा और भी टेंशन
नहीं लेना अब इसको पहले
कॉन्फिन फिगर करना है तो हम यहां पर अब जो
भी रिक्वेस्ट को है कैप्चर करना है उसके
लिए हमें बप को अपने क्लाइंट के साथ कन्फर
करना होगा क्लाइंट कौन सा है हमारा हमारा
क्लाइंट कौन सा है यह बताइए आपका क्लाइंट
कौन सा हो जो रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करता है आपके
बिफ में मुझे बता दीजिए जरा आपका क्लाइंट
कौन सा होता है जो आपके बिफ में रिक्वेस्ट
सेंड करता है एवरीवन लेट मी नो इन द चैट
बॉक्स देखते हैं कितने लोगों को क्या पता
है हु इज द क्लाइंट हु सेंड रिक्वेस्ट ऑन
योर
बिहा मुझे बता दीजिए कौन होता
है लेट मी
नो ओके पीसी
ब्राउजर सभी लोग बताइए सभी लोग बताइए यार
सभी लोग का आंसर सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए
प्लीज ब्राउजर ब्राउजर
ब्राउजर ओके सो करेक्ट या करेक्ट आंसर इज
एब्सलूट एब्सलूट करेक्ट आंसर इज ब्राउजर
101 लोग देख रहे हैं और लाइक 80 है बस कल
तो यार जितने देख रहे उससे ज्यादा लाइक्स
थी लाइक्स के लिए तो मैं मतलब बोल सकता
हूं ना यार है ना इतना तो ब है चलिए
ब्राउजर बहुत बढ़िया जो भी ब्राउजर है
आपका करेंटली आपका अभी आपके मैंने अभी के
पर्सपेक्टिव में बोला अभी के सिनेरियो में
पूछा था आपसे तो ब्राउजर है बढ़िया तो
ब्राउजर में हम बर्ब को कन्फर करेंगे बर्ब
को कंफिल करने के लिए यहां पे हमारे पास
एक बॉब का टैब होता है दैट टैब इज नोन एज
प्रॉक्सी तो प्रॉक्सी वाले आपको टैब पे
चलना है प्रॉक्सी वाले टैब पे जब आप जाओगे
तो यहां पे आपको प्रॉक्सी सेटिंग मिलेगी
यह लेटेस्ट वर्जन में इस तरीके से दिख रही
है ओल्ड वर्जन में थोड़ा डिफरेंट था इसका
जो डिस्प्ले था प्रॉक्सी सेटिंग्स प आप आ
जाएंगे प्रॉक्सी सेटिंग्स पर जब आप आएंगे
तो यहां पे प्रॉक्सी की सेटिंग्स ओपन हो
जाएगी एंड यहां पे आपको एक प्रॉक्सी लिनर
देखने को मिलेगा ना व्हाट दिस लिनर इ लिनर
का मतलब क्या होता है लिसन का मतलब होता
है कि जितने
भी इनकमिंग एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट होंगे वह
इनकमिंग रिक्वेस्ट किसी पर भी हो किसी के
साइट से हो जो आपके ब्राउजर साइट जो आपका
क्लाइंट
है जो भी क्लाइंट है जो ब्राउजर है उसके
साइड से जो भी इनकमिंग रिक्वेस्ट आएंगी वो
इसी आईपी और पोर्ट के थ्रू होके जाएंगी
यही आईपी पोर्ट उसको रिसीव करेगा कि वेलकम
भाई वेलकम रिक्वेस्ट भाई आपका वेलकम है तो
यह जो आईपी है जो बाय डिफॉल्ट आपको यहां
मिल रही है यह आपकी लूप बैक आईपी होती है
लोकल होस्ट की जो आईपी होती है लूप बैक
आईपी जो कि एक डिफॉल्ट एडॉप्टर होता है
आपके सिस्ट सिस्टम में वही है जैसे मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं यह हर एक के सिस्टम
में होता है जब आप कमांड प्रोमट ओपन करोगे
अपने विंडोज में भी या अपने
स्टार्ट करते हैं आईएफ कॉन्फिन पे एक लूप
बैक एडाप्टर एलो नाम से ये आपको दिखेगा
यहां पे इसकी आईपी एड्रेस
127.0 व आपको दिख रही है ये एक आपको लूप
बैक आईपी एड्रेस आपके हर एक सिस्टम पे
आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा एंड आप उसी में
इसकी कॉन्फिन क्या करेंगे करेंगे उसी लूप
बैक आईपी पे ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यहां पे कर
रहा होता है तो चलिए अब मैं यहां पे दिखा
देता हूं जैसे आप सेटिंग्स में गए अब यहां
पे आईपी है और इस पोर्ट पे ही लेसनर है अब
मैं क्या करता हूं गाइज व्हाट आई एम गोइंग
टू डू आई एम गोइंग टू कन्फ फिगर दिस
पर्टिकुलर आईपी एंड पोर्ट इन माय क्लाइंट
इन माय क्लाइंट ब्राउजर चलिए तो आप
क्लाइंट ब्राउजर में कॉन्फिन करेंगे अब
यहां पर एक लिसन है यहां और भी लिसन को ऐड
करने का ऑप्शंस है इसका मतलब क्या हुआ
व्हाट इट मींस क्यों ऐड करेंगे और लिसन को
भैया जब हम मल्टीपल डिवाइस से टेस्ट कर
रहे हैं मान लो हम पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे
हैं मान लो मेरे पास एक एंड्राइड फोन ये
तो हम अभी अपने सिस्टम में कर रहे इसमें
विंडोज काली मशीन में मान लो मेरे पास एक
रियल हार्डवेयर है लेट्स सपोज आई हैव अ
हार्डवेयर जिस पर मुझे टेस्ट करनी है मान
लो मेरे पास मान लो मेरे पास एक एंड्राइड
फोन है रियल हार्डवेयर है उस पर उसके
ट्रैफिक को कैप्चर करना है उस ट्रैफिक को
इंटरसेप्ट करना है तो मैं उसके लिए अलग से
लिनर बना दूंगा ऐड करके एंड यहां पर एक
पोर्ट मेंशन कर दूंगा और पर्टिकुलर जो
आईपी एड्रेस से बाइंडर है मुझे वो आईपी
एड्रेस मैं यहां पे बाइंडर दूंगा
उसको ठीक है जो हमारा पर्टिकुलर करंट आईपी
एड्रेस हमारे प्राइवेट आईपी उसे बाइंडर
देंगे ट्स इट तो हमारा काम हो जाएगा उसी
तरीके से मल्टीपल डिवाइस के लिए मल्टीपल
लिसन जो है ना वो यहां पे ऐड कर सकते हैं
फिलहाल हमारा डिफॉल्ट ये है हम इसको ऐड
करने वाले हैं किसमें firefox.exe
मैनुअल प्रॉक्सी कन्फेशन प आके आपको वो
वाली आईपी यहां डालनी है
127.0 0.1 एंड पोर्ट नंबर जो 8080 पोर्ट
है वो यहां आपको डाल देनी है उसके बाद
ध्यान रखना आपको यह टिक करके रखना है
आल्सो यूज दिस प्रॉक्सी फॉर एचटीटीपीएस
यानी एसटीपीएस कने कनेक्शंस के लिए भी
आपको यह प्रॉक्सी यूज करनी है इसको टिक कर
दीजिएगा एंड उसके बाद आप कर दीजिएगा प्रेस
ओके बस पहला स्टेप यह रहा ठीक है आपने
प्रॉक्सी को कॉन्फिन कर दिया दूसरा स्टेप
क्या है जब आप प्रॉक्सी को कॉन्फिन कर
देंगे तो आप जब यहां पर कोई वेबसाइट ओपन
करेंगे जैसे मैं अभी google.com ओपन कर
रहा हूं तो मेरा बहुत ही नॉर्मली ओपन हो
गया बट आप करेंगे तो आपको एक सर्टिफिकेट
वार्निंग मिलेगी व क्यों क्योंकि जब आप
किसी भी प्रॉक्सी लिसन को सेटअप करते हैं
अपने ब्राउजर में तो आपके ब्राउजर को
बताना पड़ता है कि भैया यह सर्टिफिकेट
उनको ब्राउजर को सर्टिफिकेट जो है ब्राउजर
के अंदर में आपको इंपोर्ट करना पड़ता है
एंड ब्राउजर को ऑथेंटिसिटी के लिए वो
सर्टिफिकेट चाहिए कि भैया ठीक है आप जो
प्रॉक्सी को आप जो अपने इंटरसेप्ट कर रहे
हो जो भी रिक्वेस्ट को वो ऑथेंटिक कर रहे
हो ना ऐसा तो नहीं कि कोई एक मलिसिया हैकर
या कोई मलिसिया अटैकर उस रिक्वेस्ट को
कैप्चर कर रहा है आपके बिहाव में तो आपको
वो सर्टिफिकेट के थ्रू ऑथेंटिक सेट
ऑथेंटिकेट करना पड़ता है एंड उसके लिए
आपको एक सर्टिफिकेट को इंस्टॉल करनी
पड़ेगी अपने ब्राउजर के अंदर में एंड उसको
कौन सा सर्टिफिकेट वो है आपका सीए
सर्टिफिकेट जो आपके बर्प का है अब इसके दो
तरीके हैं आप बर्प में
जाओ यहां पे बर्प में चले जाओ यहां आप
जाओगे प्रॉक्सी सेटिंग्स पे तो यहां पे
आपको एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा इंपोर्ट या
एक्सपोर्ट सीए सर्टिफिकेट जब आप इस पे
करोगे तो आपको एक्सपोर्ट करना है
एक्सपोर्ट सर्टिफिकेट इन डीआर फॉर्मेट तो
आप यहां से सर्टिफिकेट को एक्सपोर्ट कर
सकते हो नेक्स्ट करोगे चूज अ फाइल टू
एक्सपोर्ट द सीए सर्टिफिकेट आपको एक फाइल
सेलेक्ट कर लेनी है जो भी फाइल वगैरह जो
भी है वो सेलेक्ट कर लेनी है और
सर्टिफिकेट को एक्सपोर्ट कर देनी है तो
आपका सर्टिफिकेट एक्सपोर्ट हो जाएगा या तो
आप यहां से डायरेक्टली ब्राउजर से भी यह
फीचर कर सकते हो यूज़ कर सकते हो क्या
करना है भैया आपको यहां पे जाना है
httpbit.ly सली क्या करना है इसको डाउनलोड
कर लेना है क्लिक करोगे डाउनलोड हो जाएगी
जैसे यहां पे ये डाउनलोड हो गई अब इसको
इंपोर्ट कर देना है आपके ब्राउजर में फिर
से सेटिंग्स में चलनी है यहां चलना है
यहां सर्च करना है सर्टिफिकेट्स व्यू
सर्टिफिकेट्स पे आना है यहां आ जाएंगे
इंपोर्ट पे इंपोर्ट प क्लिक करेंगे देखो
जैसे मैं एक बार करके दिखा ही देता हूं
इंपोर्ट पे मैं पहले वाला जो सर्टिफिकेट
है ना उसको मैं व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू
डिलीट उसको मैं हटा देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए ताकि आपको मैं यहां पे लाइव इंपोर्ट
करके दिखा देता हूं तो मैं यहां पे पहले
वाले को डिलीट और डिस्ट्रेस कर देता हूं
ओके कर देता हूं एंड
दैट्ची टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
टीफाई करेगी ना यार तो करोगे ना यह करके
आपको कर देना है ओके एंड यहां पे आपको कर
देना है ओके एंड उसके बाद आपको
google.com मैंने हमारी कंपनी के वेबसाइट
को ओपन कर दिया मान लो तो हमने f.com ओपन
किया भैया ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अब हमें
इसको इंटरसेप्ट करना है इंटरसेप्ट करने का
मतलब है मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया था
इंटरसेप्ट करने का क्या मतलब है मतलब है
कि हमें एकएक ट्रैफिक को रोक देना है जो
ट्रैफिक जो रिक्वेस्ट यहां से क्लाइंट से
सर्वर की तरफ जा रही है उसको बीच में रोक
दो पढ़ो उसको समझो उसपे प्रोसेसेस करो उस
परे अलग-अलग जो भी चीजें काम जो भी
आपको जो भी आपको परफॉर्म करना है स्टेप्स
परफॉर्म करो एंड देन उसको छोड़ो देन उसको
आगे जाने दो उससे पहले मत जाने दो तो मुझे
अगर कोई चीज इंटरसेप्ट करनी है तो मुझे
इंटरसेप्ट जो ऑफ है इसको ऑन करना पड़ता
है
पहले तो मैं इसको पहले ऑन करूंगा जो कहां
पे आता है प्रॉक्सी टैब पे आता है अभी हम
एक-एक टैब को समझेंगे फिलहाल के लिए मैं
इंटरसेप्ट का एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल दे रहा
हूं बस इसको भी मैं समझाऊं अच्छे से तो
इंटरसेप्ट को पहले हम ऑन करेंगे ऑन जैसे
ही कर लेंगे हम ब्राउजर पे जाएंगे और अब
हम किसी भी पेज को विजिट करेंगे किसी भी
पेज को जैसे मैं अकेडमी पेज को विजिट कर
रहा हूं लेट्स सपोज तो जैसे ही मैं क्लिक
करूंगा इस पे क्योंकि इंटर ऑन है हमारा
यहां पे इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन तो मैं जैसे ही
क्लिक करूंगा इस पे जो हमारा बब शूट है वो
उस रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर कर लेगा जैसे देखो
मैं इंटरसेप्ट प क्लिक किया सॉरी अकेडमी प
क्लिक करते ही यह देखो बब शूट ओपन हो गया
जैसे ही मैंने क्लिक करा बॉब शूट ओपन हो
गया और बॉब शूट में यह रिक्वेस्ट जो है
कैप्चर हो गई है देखो यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट
टू सबसे ऊपर देखो रिक्वेस्ट टू एचटीटीपीएस
कॉलन स् स्
academic.com कन 443 यह रिक्वेस्ट कैप्चर
हुई है यहां से समझ में आ रहा है कैप्चर
हो गई अब यह जब रिक्वेस्ट कैप्चर हो गई है
तो अब हम इस पर फदर प्रोसेसेस कर सकते हैं
इस तरीके से आप रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करते
हो पहले तो मैंने यह बताया कि आपको बस
रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करना है तो इस तरीके
से करते हो सिंपल अब अगर आपको इस
रिक्वेस्ट कैप्चर को यहीं पर ड्रॉप करना
है ड्रॉप पर क्लिक कर दीजिए यहीं पर ड्रॉप
हो जाएगी ये मतलब इसको ड्रॉप कर देगा बस
और कुछ नहीं इसको आगे फॉरवर्ड करना है
आपको फॉरवर्ड करिएगा तो आप ये नेक्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट प जाएगा देखो जैसे क्या होता है
सर्वर जब क्लाइंट सर्वर से एक रिक्वेस्ट
करता है ना तो मल्टीपल रिक्वेस्ट जाती हैं
एक रिक्वेस्ट ही नहीं जाती है सिर्फ देयर
आर मल्टीपल रिक्वेस्ट इवॉल्वड तो जब आप
फॉरवर्ड करोगे तो इसके बाद वाले जो भी
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट होगा उस पर ये चला जा
जैसे मैं फॉरवर्ड करता हूं फॉरवर्ड किया
मैंने उसके बाद एक रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे जाता
है याद रखिएगा यह रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
इसका ओरिजिन देखिए fix.com ही है रेफरल भी
fan.com ही है कहीं और नहीं जा रहा है बट
रिक्वेस्ट किसको कर रहा है facebook.com
को तो इसका यह पार्ट है फिर से फॉरवर्ड
करेंगे यह फॉरवर्ड होके जा रहा है अगेन यह
googal.com आ रही है फिर से फॉरवर्ड
करेंगे यह किसी और
google.com पे यहां पे यह आ रही है इस
तरीके से यह जा रही है अभी जब ओपन करेंगे
तो देखो अभी भी ये पूरा ओपन नहीं हुआ है
वेबसाइट क्योंकि रिक्वेस्ट को हमने कैप्चर
करके रखा है यार हमने उसको पकड़ के रखा है
ये पूरी वेबसाइट को लोड ही नहीं होने देगा
क्योंकि भैया रिक्वेस्ट तो यहां पे पड़ी
हुई है यह रिक्वेस्ट तो यहां पे कैप्चर
होके पड़ी हुई है ना आगे रिक्वेस्ट जा ही
नहीं पा रही है सर्वर तक सर्वर तक जितनी
रिक्वेस्ट गई उतना मतलब जितना अभी तक आया
उतना आपको दिख रहा
है इंटरेस्टिंग है ना इसको जरा आंखें बंद
करके बंद करके सोचो जस्ट क्लोज योर आइज
एंड जस्ट थिंक कि यह कितना इंटरेस्टिंग है
आंखें सभी लोग बंद कर लो तब तुमको
इंटरेस्ट इसके इंटरेस्टिंग का पता चलेगा
कि यह कितना इंटरेस्टिंग है इस चीज को
विजुलाइज करोगे तो आंखें बंद करो जैसे मैं
आपको बोलता हूं ना सोचो एक रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है सर्वर तक सर्वर तक जाने से पहले ही
उस रिक्वेस्ट को बब शूट नाम के एक
प्रॉक्सी टूल ने रोक लिया पकड़ लिया अब
सर्वर तक गई नहीं और आपको यह पढ़ने के लिए
बोल रहा है पढ़ भाई सॉरी आपको यह पढ़ने के
लिए बोल रहा है पढ़ भाई रिक्वेस्ट को ये
हेडर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर आपको ये पढ़ने के लिए
बोला है पढ़ो भाई क्या है ये एक तरह का
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जा रहा है होस्ट यह है
कुकी वैल्यू ये है इसमें यूजर एजेंट यह है
यह सारी चीजें कर रहा है और उसको रोक के
रखा हुआ है भैया यहां पे आगे बढ़ने नहीं
दे रहा जस्ट
इमेजिन कर रहे हो इमेजिन सबको इमेजिन कर
पा रहे हो कितनी बड़ी चीज है देखो अभी तो
तुम्हें बहुत इजी नॉर्मल चीज लग रही लेकिन
इमेजिन करोगे तो तुम्हें समझ में आएगा
कितनी बड़ी चीज है तो अब यहां पे ये
रिक्वेस्ट जैसे ये ये पेज कैसे बढ़ेगा ये
पेज आगे कैसे बढ़ेगा जब हम इस इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑफ कर देंगे इंटरसेप्ट को हम जैसे ही
ऑफ करेंगे देखो ये पेज आगे बढ़ेगा एंड आगे
जो फरदर ये ओपन होना होगा या जो भी चीजें
ओपन होना होंगी जो भी इसके पेज ओपन होने
होंगे ये ओपन हो जाएंगे ठीक है इंटरसेप्ट
ऑफ करेंगे एंड ये आगे अपना प्रोसेस कर
लेगा अभी ये वेबसाइट मे भी अभी शायद नहीं
चल रही होगी जो भी है तो इसलिए ये ओपन
नहीं होहा अदर वाइज ये आगे अपना जो भी
चीजें आगे ओपन होगी ठीक है सो मैं यहां पे
अकेडमी को वापस से ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां
पे एंड यस यह वेबसाइट में ही अभी प्रॉब्लम
है अभी शायद यह कुछ डाउन टाइम या कुछ चल
रहा होगा जैसे ऐप प आपने देखा तो ऐप का ही
है तो ये आगे प्रोसेस कर देगा जैसे अब मैं
एक और पेज का रिक्वेस्ट कर लेता हूं जैसे
ये ब्लॉग पेज है ठीक है हम इसको भी
इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं ब्लॉग को इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
किया यहां प ब्लॉक पे क्लिक किया ये ब्लॉग
यहां पे आ गई फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
किया यहां पे ब्लॉग अभी भी आपका ब्लॉग ओपन
नहीं हुआ है ब्लॉग अभी भी ये आगे लोड हो
रहा है आगे फिर से फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं एंड लेट्स सी यहां तक ये
यहां भी आ गया अभी पूरा लोड नहीं हुआ पूरी
अच्छे तरीके से इसलिए अभी क्या हो रहा है
आधा अधूरा आपको दिख रहा है ये देखो आधा
अधूरा ब्लॉक दिख रहा है अभी क्योंकि ये
पूरी तरीके से लोड नहीं हुआ है अब मैं
क्या करूंगा मैं जैसे ही इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ
करूंगा ये देखो ब्लॉक पेज पूरी तरीके से
लोड हो जाएगा अच्छे तरीके से लोड हो जाएगा
एंड यू कैन फाइंड द ब्लॉक्स हियर एंड आप
ये ब्लॉगस देखिए ये ब्लॉगस अ जो हमारे
वेबसाइट पे है काफी अच्छे ब बॉक्स काफी
अच्छे जो है यहां पे आर्टिकल्स आपको मिल
जाते हैं ठीक है चलिए तो यह तो आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा इंटरसेप्ट का मतलब अब हम
बब शूट इसको हम बंद करेंगे और हम बब शूट
प्रोफेशनल की तरफ बढ़ेंगे हम आगे की जो भी
प्रोसेसेस है उसी पे करेंगे उसके पहले हम
इसमें जो सेटिंग्स हमने किया था उसको
रिवर्ट कर देते हैं पहले जैसा था नेटवर्क
सेटिंग वो कर देते हैं अ नेटवर्क में जाइए
एंड यहां पे आपको पहले जैसे करना है नो
प्रॉक्सी पे कर दीजिए एंड ओके पे क्लिक कर
दीजिए अब आप
एंड इट विल ओपन ठीक है तो काली वाले भैया
का यहां पे हमारा काम हो जाता है इसको मैं
बंद कर देता हूं अब आते हैं विंडोज पे ठीक
है फिलहाल के लिए काली को मैं यहां से
क्लोज ही कर देता हूं इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
वैसी है नहीं अभी फिलहाल के लिए तो मैं
यहां पे काली को शट डाउन कर देता हूं
कमांड चला के एंड
दैट्ची है चलिए अब हम विज के बब शूट पे आ
जाते हैं अब विज में आप कम्युनिटी एडिशन
भी यूज कर सकते हैं डाउनलोड करके या तो
प्रोफेशनल भी अब प्रोफेशनल की बात है तो
वो मैं ज्यादा उस परे डिस्कस नहीं करूंगा
आप सब समझ रहे हैं प्रोफेशनल आप यूज कर
सकते हैं या तो आप परचेस कर लो या तो आप
जैसे भी यूज करना है करो आप सब समझ रहे
हैं मेरी बात आर यू गाइस अंडरस्टैंडिंग
व्हाट आई एम ट्राइट से आप लोग समझ रहे
क्या मेरी
बात अरे भाई बब शूट पे स्पेशल वीडियो ही
है यार क्या दिमाग दिमाग ही नहीं है यार
भाई भाई इतना स्पैम करोगे तो मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं फिर मुझे तो आपको अ वो करना
पड़ेगा बंद करना पड़ेगा आपको यार स्पैम तो
मत करो प्लीज यार इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट इट्स अ
ह्यूज
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है प्लीज डोंट स्पैम
चलिए तो आप समझ रहे हो ना व्हाट आई एम
सेइंग चलिए तो मैंने आप सबको
अ मैंने आप सबको बताया था चलिए यहां पे
जिन्होंने स्पैम किया है मैं उनको थोड़ा
इनको टाइम आउट कर देता हूं कम से कम कम से
कम 10 मिनट के लिए प्लीज डोंट स्पैम ठीक
है 10 मिनट बाद आप फिर से अब
जुड़िए चलिए अब यहां पे मैंने आपको एक
फाइल डाउनलोड करवाई थी वो फाइल ये है बब
शूट का जिप फाइल डाउनलोड करवाया था मैंने
आपको हमारे डिफं एडमी ए एप पे एंड डिप
फाइल को आप जिप फाइल को डाउनलोड कीजिएगा
तो आपके अंदर ये फोल्डर ये डाउनलोडेड
फोल्डर आपको मिलेगी इसको डबल क्लिक
कीजिएगा ओपन कीजिएगा बब शूट इस तरीके से
1.7.3 4 वर्जन मिलेगा अब दो ये मैंने
क्यों किया लेटेस्ट वर्जन क्यों नहीं यूज
कर रहे क्योंकि लेटेस्ट वर्जन में कुछ
चीजें हैं जो शायद
मुझे ज्यादा पसंद नहीं है या फिर ऐसा कहो
कि कुछ चीजें नहीं है जो मुझे पसंद ज्यादा
थी ठीक है तो जैसे कि एक आपका स्पाइडरिंग
फंक्शन हालांकि स्पाइडरिंग हो जाती है
आपकी बट स्टिल स्पाइडरिंग एक अलग से एक
अलग ही फील आती है जो मैं आपको बताऊंगा
क्या होता है बप शूट को आपको ओपन कर लेना
होता है याद रखिएगा विंडोज में जब आप बप
शूट चला रहे हैं तो आप जब जार फाइल यूज कर
रहे हैं इसका जार वर्जन यूज कर रहे हैं तो
आपको इंस्टल होनी चाहिए आपकी बप शूट की यू
मस्ट हैव इंस्टॉल जावा इसलिए मैंने इस
फाइल में ऑलरेडी जडी के आपको इंस्टॉलेशन
वाली जेडी के जो है आपको दे दी है जेडी
केड एी क्यूटेल फाइल है वह दे दी है आपको
पहले इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेना है डबल क्लिक
करके विंडोज में जैसे बाकी सॉफ्टवेर
इंस्टॉल करते हैं वैसे ही इसको आपको
इंस्टॉल कर लेना
है ठीक है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल इंस्टॉल करने
के बाद आपको जावा के पाथ को एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल के अंदर जाकर सेटअप कर लेना है व
कैसे करना है वह भी मैं बता देता हूं जावा
की पाथ जब आप इसको इंस्टॉल कर लोगे ना तो
इसकी दो पाथ क्रिएट हो जाएगी कैसे आप जाओ
सी ड्राइव में यहां जाओ प्रोग्राम फाइल्स
में आई थिंक सो प्रोग्राम फाइल्स में जावा
पे जाओ जावा पे जाओगे तो आपको एक जेडी के
1.8.0 समथिंग मिलेगा और एक जे आर 1.8
मिलेगा यह दोनों का जो पाथ है उसको सेट
करना है पहले जेडी के पे चलते हैं उसको
ओपन करते हैं और इसका कौन सा पाथ सेट करना
है बिन के अंदर का बिन पे जाइएगा एंड इसकी
जो पूरी पाथ ऊपर आपको दिख रही है इसको
कॉपी मार लीजिए यहां क्लिक कीजिए एड्रेस
बार में एंड यहां पे इसको सिंपली राइट
क्लिक करके कॉपी मारिए एंड इसको
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल के अंदर सेटअप कर देना
है कहां मिलेगा एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल भैया
तो आप सीधा विंडोज बटन सर्च स्टार्ट कीजिए
एंड यहां पे आप कंट्रोल पैनल में जाके
सिस्टम सेटिंग्स में जाके कर सकते हैं बट
यहां पे डायरेक्टली आप एनवायरमेंट सर्च
कीजिए इतना ज्यादा टाइम हमें नहीं लेना
यहां पे ऑप्शन आ जाएगा एडिट द सिस्टम
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल तो आपको इसको ओपन कर
लेना है ओपन करोगे तो सिस्टम की प्रॉपर्टी
जो है वो खुल जाएगी जहां पे आपका कंप्यूटर
नेम वगैरह आता है हार्डवेयर की डिटेल्स
हार्डवेयर के बारे में एडवांस सेटिंग्स
आती हैं इसी एडवांस सिस्टम और सिस्टम
प्रोटेक्शन आता है ज जहां पर रिस्टोर
पॉइंट आपका क्रिएट होता है सी ड्राइव में
याद रखिएगा आप सबको मैं एक चीज बता देता
हूं आप सबके लैपटॉप में यह एक एडिशनल टिप
है जब सिस्टम प्रॉपर्टीज पर आप आएंगे तो
सिस्टम प्रोटेक्शन के अंदर सी जो ड्राइव
है सिस्टम वाली ्र जिसमें आपका विंडोज
इंस्टॉल्ड है उसका प्रोटेक्शन ऑन रखिएगा
हमेशा बाय डिफॉल्ट ऑन ही होगा बट आपका अगर
बाय चांस ऑफ है तो उसको ऑन करके रखिएगा
तभी आपका रिस्टोर पॉइंट क्रिएट होता है
आपके सिस्टम में यानी कि जब आपके सिस्टम
में कोई ऐसी कोई वायरस आ जाती है या कोई
ऐसा रंस वेयर टाइप कुछ ऐसा आ जाता है
जिससे सिस्टम आपका बेकार हो जा रहा है या
आपको प्रीवियस डेट में रिस्टोर करना है
प्रीवियस ऐसी डेट में जब सिस्टम आपका सही
था अगर वैसा करना है तो आप ये ऑन रखना
जरूरी है नहीं तो रिस्टोर पॉइंट क्रिएट
नहीं होगा ऑटोमेटिक एंड आप नहीं कर पाएंगे
रिस्टोर ठीक है तो इसको आप ऑन देख लीजिएगा
चेक कर लीजिएगा डी ऑफ भी रहे चलेगा तो
यहां हम आते हैं एडवांस सेटिंग्स पे यहां
आते हैं एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल पे एंड यहां
आएंगे तो यहां पे एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल में
आपको यह सिस्टम वेरिएबल के अंदर में यहां
पे एक पाथ नाम का ऑप्शन दिखेगा पाथ वाला
जो एंट्री है वह दिखेगा पाथ वाली एंट्री
पे आपको जाना है एंड यहां पे आपको एडिट कर
देना है एडिट करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको
दोनों पाथ ऐड करना है एक जेआर का जेडीके
का दोनों का देख रहे होगे मेरे दोनों डेड
है यहां पे जे आरई भी ऐडेड है जेडीके ऐडेड
है आप आपको नया एडिट करना है न्यू पे
क्लिक कीजिएगा यहां पे आपने जो पाथ कॉपी
किया था उसको पेस्ट मार दीजिएगा जेडी के
वाली एंड
दैट्ची आती है आपकी जे आरई की इस पे आ
जाइएगा बिन पे आ जाइएगा एंड इसको कॉपी
करके एंड अगेन सेम प्रोसेस अप्लाई करना
एंड सेम पाथ को एडिट करना एंड यहां पे आके
सेम उसी तर तरीके से न्यू पे करके एंड
यहां पे वो वाली पेस्ट कर देना एंड
दैट्ची है बिकॉज़ इट्स नॉट गुड अ हम जो भी
करेंगे लीगली करेंगे बाकी आप समझदार हैं
एंड आई विल ट्राई टू अ सेंड अ शॉर्ट
वीडियो रिगार्डिंग दिस ऑन
whatsapp2 पे देख लीजिएगा
से पहले आपको
whatsapp2
whatsapp2 में मिल जाएगी बात सही ठीक है
बढ़िया मैं बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया मजा आ
रहा है मजा आ रहा है ना सेशन में चलो अब
यहां पे मैं इस बप शूट को ओपन करूंगा तो
मैं कैसे ओपन करूंगा पहले मैं इसको बंद कर
देता हूं ये क्या है यार ये क्या ओपन रह
गया हट जाओ अ अब मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं
मैं लोडर से ही ओपन होगा हमेशा बब शूट
वाले से नहीं होगा हमेशा ओपन सिर्फ लोडर
से होगा मैं करके रन पे क्लिक करूंगा अब
ये मेरा तो चल रहा है आपका भी चलेगा जब
आपका सब कुछ सही कॉन्फिन हो जाएगा तो तो
यहां बब शूट मैंने ओपन कर लिया नेक्स्ट पे
क्लिक कर करूंगा स्टार्ट पे क्लिक करूंगा
एंड
दैट्ची जें हैं जो हमें चाहिए जो हमारे
लिए रिक्वायर्ड है इंपॉर्टेंट है ओके
चलिए अब आ जाते हैं प्रॉक्सी पे प्रॉक्सी
पे आके सबसे पहले देखेंगे इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
रहेगा बाय डिफॉल्ट ऑफ कर दीजिएगा ठीक है
कोई फायदा नहीं
है ऑप्शंस पे आ जाते हैं ऑप्शंस पे आके यह
वाली आईपी कॉन्फिन करनी है आपके ब्राउजर
में तो ब्राउजर हमारा ये रहा firefox.exe
आपके लिए अब बहुत इजी हो गया मैनुअल
प्रॉक्सी पे आना है ये आईपी पोर्ट दे देनी
है यूज फॉर एचटीटीपीएस करके ओके कर देना
है एंड
[संगीत]
दैट्ची है चलिए तो सबसे पहला टैब जो आपको
बर्ब शूट के अंदर मिलता
लेट्स
वेट तो हमने क्या किया ब इंस्टॉलेशन को
देख लिया बप टैब्स के बारे में अब जानते
हैं आप सबको चाहिए कि मैं बब शूट की
इंस्टॉलेशन एक्टिवेशन एक्चुअली बब शूट
प्रोफेशनल की वीडियो ट चैनल पर आपको बना
के भेज द शॉर्ट वीडियो छोटा सा वीडियो
होगा उसमें सब कुछ आपको स्टेप्स बता दूंगा
आप सबको चाहिए ऐसा मुझे बता चैट में जल्दी
से जल्दी
से बताइए एवरीवन वांट्स
जल्दी बता दीजिए फटाफट ताकि हम आगे
प्रोसीड करें
भैया ठीक है इफ यू वांट चैनल प आपको मिल
जाएगा एंड उस पर एक्टिव रहिए चैनल प आप
लोग बिल्कुल एक्टिव रहिए डेली चेक कीजिए
अपडेट्स के लिए हमेशा चैनल में स्टेटस में
जाके ली चेक किया कीजिए
ओके अच्छा आप लोग में से रिप्लाई बहुत कम
लोग कर रहे हैं यार मतलब अभी 90 लोग लोग
के आसपास देख रहे हैं रिप्लाई बहुत कम
नहीं लग
रहा और लाइक भी यार सबने नहीं किया ना
लाइक सबने नहीं किया ना मतलब कुछ लोगों को
अच्छा नहीं भी लग रहा है मुझे ऐसा लग रहा
है कोई बात नहीं यार फ्री की ट्रेनिंग है
लाइक कर दो क्या जाता है लाइक करने में
आपका कुछ पैसा सा लग रहा है तो फिर मत करो
क्या कर सकते हैं भाई
ओके
चलिए
लिनिक्स में भी सेम चीजें कर सकते हैं
ब्रदर सेम तरीके से यू कैन कंफिल चलिए तो
हम यहां पे पहले टैब को समझते हैं टारगेट
टैब अब यहां पे क्या है आपको मैं पहले
समझाता हूं टारगेट टैब यह क्या है किस
तरीके से काम करता है एवरीथिंग वी विल
अंडरस्टैंड एवरीथिंग वी विल अंडरस्टैंड
पहले मैं इसको पूरा टारगेट टैब जो है इसको
मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं कहां गया रिमूव
फ्रॉम स्कोप स्कोप पे कौनसा डाल दिया भाई
डिलीट सिलेक्टेड आइटम्स यस सबको मैं डिलीट
कर देता हूं बहुत बढ़िया अब मैं यहां पे
एक एक वेबसाइट ओपन करता हूं टेस्ट पीएचपी
टेस्ट
पीएचपी वन हब यह एक एक टेस्टिंग वेबसाइट
है मैं इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं ठीक है आई एम
जस्ट ओपनिंग इट यहां पर मैंने ओपन कर लिया
जैसे ही मैं ओपन
करूंगा ठीक है जैसे ही मैं ओपन करूंगा
गाइस यह जो टेस्ट टारगेट टैब है इसके अंदर
दो चीजें हैं साइट मैप एंड स्कोप एंड एक
यहां फिल्टर ठीक है यह जो डैशबोर्ड आपको
दिख रहा है सामने वहां प यहां पे एक पैनल
यह है एक कंटेंट का पैनल है एक रिक्वेस्ट
रिस्पांस का पैनल है एक इश्यूज का पैनल एक
एडवाइजरी का पैनल है ठीक है यह सारे
पैनल्स है ये ऊपर में सारे मेन्यू हैं यह
मेन मेन्यूस है आपके एंड ये आपके सब
मेन्यूस हैं इसके अंदर अब हम टारगेट में
सबसे पहला होता है साइट मैप जो कि आप जो
भी वेबसाइट्स को विजिट कर रहे हैं जो भी
वेबसाइट्स को ओपन कर रहे हैं वो सारे यहां
पे लिस्टेड हो जाएंगे सारे यहां पे ओपन हो
जाएंगे जैसे मैंने टेस्ट पीएचपी ओपन किया
अभी ये वेबसाइट ओपन की t php.net क ये
यहां पे लिस्टेड होगी चलिए देख लेते हैं
कहां पे लिस्टेड है भैया कहां है कहां है
कहां है यह तो वन वेब है टेस्ट पीएचपी
टेस्ट पीएचपी ये रही यह रही टेस्ट पीएपी .
1 web.com यह वेबसाइट यहां पे आपको यहां
पे लिस्टेड मिल रही है तो जो भी आप
वेबसाइट ओपन करेंगे इट विल गेट लिस्टेड
हियर जैसे मैं यहां पे अब फ्रक्स ओपन कर
देता हूं dex.com एंटर करते हैं एंड इट
शुड गेट रिफ्लेक्टेड इन दिस जब आप नीचे
आएंगे नीचे आएंगे देखिए यहां पर डेनिक्स
कहीं ओपन हुआ कहीं प कहीं प कहीं प आया
क्या f.com यह रही f.com यहां पर यह लिस्ट
हो चुकी है सो वी गट द डि फ्रक्स इन द
साइट मैप यह होता है हमारा साइट मैप ठीक
है अब अब यहां पर एक चीज आती है क्या यहां
पर आती है एक स्कोप यह क्यों जरूरी है
स्कोप इज वेरी मच इंपोर्टेंट वाई वाई भैया
क्यों जरूरी है क्योंकि स्कोप ऑप्शन प जब
ज आप आओगे तो इसमें आप स्पेसिफिक स्कोप को
ऐड कर पाओगे स्पेसिफिक टारगेट को और सिर्फ
उसी टारगेट पे आगे हंट करोगे अब यह देखो
ना साइट प प कितने कचड़े यहां पे आ चुके
हैं यार ये जितने रिक्वेस्ट है सबको यहां
पे डाल के रखा है सारी चीजें आ गई सारी जो
यूआरएल है सारे जो रिक्वेस्ट है सारे मतलब
जितने यूआरएल है सब आ गए नहीं मुझे तो यार
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल को चेक करना है बस ओनली
मुझे चाहिए कि मैं बस fix.com को चेक करूं
और मुझे चाहिए कि मैं बस अ टेस्ट पीएचपी व
वेब को चेक करूं तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा
मैं इनको स्कोप में ऐड कर दूंगा जिस पे
मुझे हंट करना है जिस पे मुझे जो मेरा
टारगेट है तो मैं राइट क्लिक करूंगा ऐड टू
स्कोप कर दूंगा एंड यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए
आप जो लाइक यू हैव आइट डू यू वांट टू बप
प्रॉक्सी टू स्टॉप सेंडिंग आउट ऑफ स्कोप
आइटम्स टू द हिस्ट्री और अदर बब टूल्स तो
ऐसा मुझे नहीं चाहिए तो मैं नो कर दूंगा
यहां पे स्कोप में ऐड कर दिया अब मुझे
चाहिए टेस्ट पीएचपी को भी ऐड करने स्कोप
में तो मैं टेस्ट पीएचपी पे राइट क्लिक
करूंगा ऐड टू स्कोप करूंगा एंड
दैट्ची दोनों जो है दिखेंगे इन द
स्कोप यह स्कोप में है हमारे टारगेट कौन
सा f.com और टेस्ट
जो रिक्वेस्ट टाइप्स है उससे फिल्टर
फिल्टर बाय सर्च टर्म सर्च कर सकते हो
पर्टिकुलर कोई भी एक पर्टिकुलर स्ट्रिंग
को सर्च कर सकते हो रिजेक्स अप्लाई कर
सकते हो सब कुछ फिल्टर बा एम आई एमई टाइप
मतलब पर्टिकुलर टाइप ऑफ रिसोर्स को आप
फिल्टर कर सकते हो मुझे सिर्फ
जावास्क्रिप्ट चाहिए तो जावास्क्रिप्ट
एचटीएमएल चाहिए तो एचटीएमएल सीएसएस चाहिए
तो सीएसएस एक्सल चाहिए तो एक्सम सिफ इमेजे
चाहिए तो इमेजेस यह सारे आप फिल्टर्स लगा
सकते हो फिल्टर बाय फाइल एक्सटें मुझे
फाइल एक्सटेंशंस और कुछ ऐड करने हैं ऐड कर
दीजिए मुझे अभी फिलहाल यहां पे डिफॉल्ट
में एसपी एपी एक जेएसपी एंड पीएचपी है
चाहिए तो आप एचटीएमएल ऐड कर लो चाहिए तो
जावा ऐड कर लो जो भी आपको एक्सटेंशन ऐड
करने है ऐड कर लो हाइड कौन-कौन से करने
हैं तो ये सारे हाइड करने हैं चाहे तो और
ऐड कर लो या हटा दो फिल्टर बाई स्टेटस
कोड्स मतलब आपको कौन-कौन से स्टेटस कोड्स
आपको चाहिए तो बाय डिफॉल्ट ू एक्सएसएस
वाले सारे 200 और 200 से ऊपर वाले जितने
भी 2 एक्सस स्टेटस कोड है इंक्लूडेड है
थ्री एंड फाइव इंक्लूडेड है फोर इंक्लूडेड
नहीं होता इसको हम टिक कर देंगे फोर इज
आल्सो इंपॉर्टेंट 404 नॉट फाउंड 40 अ फोर
का नॉट फाउंड का मतलब आप समझ रहे होंगे
वहां कुछ नहीं है मतलब वहां कुछ तो है 404
इज अ लिटरली वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग आपको
क्या पता है 404 के बारे में नॉट फाउंड
मतलब वहां कुछ है नहीं मतलब वहां कुछ हो
सकता है 404 नॉट फाउंड का मतलब बहुत अजीब
है नॉट फाउंड लेकिन वहां कुछ ना कुछ आपको
मिल सकता है ये भी जान लीजिए ठीक है बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है इसको टिक कर लेंगे
फोल्डर्स को आप कर सकते हैं फिल्टर हाइड
एमटी फोल्डर जो एमटी फोल्डर उसको हाइड कर
दो कोई बात नहीं चलेगा ठीक है ना ये सारी
चीज आप कर सकते हैं तो हम यहां पे स्कोप
आइटम्स को क्या करेंगे फिल्टर करेंगे कैसे
शो ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स तो ये सिर्फ इन
स्कोप वाले को ही
दिखाएगा यह पहला इसका बेनिफिट है फिल्टर
का इसके अलावा एक और शानदार बेनिफिट है वो
भी आपको समझना है तो मैंने इस पर क्लिक
करके एंटर किया अब ये देखो सिर्फ दो ही
दिखा रहा है एक डि फ्रक्स और एक टेस्ट
पीएचपी ट्स इट अब कितना क्लियर हो गया य
पे कचड़े सारे हट गए गट इट एवरीवन समझ में
आ गया समझ में आ गया कौन सा कहां पर ब्लॉक
हो जाते हो ब्लॉक नहीं होते एप्लीकेशन प
ऑटोमेटिक ब्लॉक होता है मैं नहीं ब्लॉक
करता यार मुझे इतना टाइम नहीं है मैं
ब्लॉक नहीं करता ऑटोमेटिक कुछ उल्टा
पुल्टा कर रहे हो कुछ गलत सत इंफॉर्मेशन
डाल रहे हो बारबार कुछ कर रहे हो ट्राई
मार रहे हो तो ग वो ब्लॉक हो जाएगा फिर से
मैं अनब्लॉक करवा देता हूं टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है कुछ टाइम बाद अनब्लॉक ऑटोमेटिक हो
जाओगे तुम तो यहां पर हमारा आ
चुका बिगिनर्स के लिए कौन सा अच्छा होगा
काली या पैरेट काली के साथ जाओ काली के
साथ अब यहां पर हमने फिल्टर कर दिया अब
इसके बाद एक और चीज है क्या चीज है यहां
पर जब आओगे फिल्टर में तो एक और फिल्टर है
शो ओनली पैरामीटराइज रिक्वेस्ट ऐसे
रिक्वेस्ट जिसमें पैरामीटर हो पैरामीटर
क्या होता है सबको पता है क्या व्ट द
पैरामीटर इ पैरामीटर का मतलब क्या होता है
एवरीवन नोज सबको पता है भैया जल्दी
बताइए जल्दी बताइए आईपी की क्लास समझ नहीं
आया आदर्श फिर से देखिए आदर्श समझ में आ
जाएगा पैरामीटर का मतलब क्या होता है
एवरीवन लेट मी नो सबको पता है क्या
पैरामीटर का
मतलब एवरीवन
नो कितने लोगों को पता
है
नो नो नो नो काफी लोगों को नहीं
पता ओके काफी लोगों को नहीं पता चलिए
बढ़िया अब देखो पैरामीटर क्या होता है मैं
आपको एक एग्जांपल से समझा देता हूं
पैरामीटर क्या होता है ठीक है व्ट द
पैरामीटर चलिए इसको मैं एग्जांपल के थू
समझाता
हूं ठीक है
जैसे जैसे र क्या होता है देखिए जैसे मेरे
पास एक यूआरएल है एक यूआरएल है
अ एक यूआरएल है fix.com
ये मेरा नॉर्मल सा एक यूआरएल है fix.com
ये एक नॉर्मल सा यूआरएल है एंड दिस यूआरएल
इज लेट्स सपोज अभी जो है यह विदाउट
पैरामीटर है मान लो मतलब अभी विदाउट
पैरामीटर इसको बोलेंगे विदाउट पैरामीटर बट
मेरे पास एक और यूआरएल है एक और यूआरएल है
जैसे मैं कोई सा भी ओपन करके देख लेता हूं
कुछ अगर ओपन हो जाता है तो अदर वाइज आई
विल शो
यू कुछ अलग तरीके से यहां पे आपको ओपन
नहीं होगा क्योंकि पैरामीटराइज चीजें यहां
पे ओपन होगी नहीं बट यहां पे मैं इस पे
चलता हूं मान लो प्रोफाइल पे चलता हूं इस
वाले पे चलता हूं या मैं यहां चलता हूं
ब्राउज आर्टिस्ट पे चलता हूं एंड कमेंट ऑन
दिस आर्टिकल पे चलता हूं इस पे करता हूं
अब एक मेरे पास एक ये यूआरएल आ गई एक ये
यूआरएल आ गई यह वाली ठीक है अब देखो यहां
पे ये एक नॉर्मल सा जनरल यूआरएल है विदाउट
पैरामीटर एंड ये जो यूआरएल है आपका इसमें
लास्ट में आप देखोगे ए आईडी इक्वल
टूव ए आईडी इक्वल
टूव दिस ए आईडी इज
पैरामीटर जिसकी एक वैल्यू है उसी तरीके से
आईडी इक्वल
टूव आईडी इज अ पैरामीटर काट इ इक्वल टू
बुक्स यह काट एक पैरामीटर हो जाएगा यूजर इ
यूजर आईडी इ इक्वल टू 1 2 3 4 5 यूजर आईडी
विल बी अ
पैरामीटर समझ में आ
गया तो यह पैरामीटर्स होते हैं तो जितने
पैरामीटर्स होते हैं उनमें जितने भी
पैरामीटर्स होते हैं मोस्टली पैरामीटर्स
पे ही हम मैक्सिमम वलने बिलिटी को ट्राई
आउट करते हैं मैक्सिमम वले एबिलिटीज को हम
फाइंड आउट करते हैं मैक्सिमम लेबिलिटी को
तो ये पैरामीटर्स वाले जो रिक्वेस्ट है वो
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट होते हैं जैसे कि इस
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट को जब यहां पर स्कैन
करके यहां रिजल्ट्स आए यह कंटेंट है जहां
पर सारे स्कैन होके क्रॉल होक रिजल्ट्स
आपको मिले हैं तो यहां पर यह जो पैरम लिखा
हुआ है यह वही पैरामीटर है एंड य टिक मारा
हुआ है यानी कि यह सारे जो यूआरएल है जिस
पर टिक मारा हुआ है यह पैरामीटराइज यूआरएल
है यानी इसमें कोई पैरामीटर है कुछ ना कुछ
जो इसकी एक वैल्यू है जिसका एक कोई वैल्यू
डिफाइंड है जिसका एक वैल्यू है वो
पैरामीटर यूआरएल उसको बोलते हैं या सर्च इ
इक्टी हैकिंग
या
या ठीक है अब चलिए फिल्टर प चलते हैं शो
ओनली पैरामीटराइज रिक्वेस्ट पर चलते हैं
एंड ट्स इट क्लिक कर देते हैं अब यहां पर
जो रिक्वेस्ट आपको शो हो रहे हैं यह सारे
यह सारे पैरामीटराइज रिक्वेस्ट है यह
जितने भी है वह सारे पैरामीटराइज
रिक्वेस्ट
है कितने रिक्वेस्ट है एक दोती च पा 6 सा
ओनली सात है
पैरामीटराइज अब इसमें आपको यहां पर एक
स्टेटस दिख रहा है
200 यहां पर क्या दिख रहा है 200 यानी कि
यह जो पैरामीटराइज रिक्वेस्ट है यह 200
यानी कि यह वर्किंग है यह सही है यह
करेक्ट है आप इस पर कोई फदर काम कर सकते
हैं बाकी जो है इसका कोई हमें स्टेटस काट
का पता नहीं है तो वी शुड डेफिनेटली गेट
स्टिक टू दिस पैरामीटर यूआरएल जिसमें
स्टेटस को 200 200 का मतलब ओके मतलब सर्वर
से कनेक्टिविटी है मतलब व चल रहा है काम
उसका काम चल रहा है दिस इज द पैरामीटराइज
रिक्वेस्ट तो हम यहां पर फिल्टर करके यह
लगा सकते फिल्टर लगा के यह कर सकते हैं अब
हमें कोई पर्टिकुलर सर्च टर्न सर्च करना
है तो जैसे मुझे फाइल ये सर्च करनी है मैं
यहां पे फाइल ऐसे करके यहां पे सर्च
करूंगा तो अगर मुझे कुछ ऐसा फाइल से
रिलेटेड कुछ भी मिलता है तो मुझे यहां पे
ये आ जाएगा रिफ्लेक्ट कर जाएगा मुझे यहां
पे क्या हो जाएगी मिल जाएगी जैसे कि मुझे
अगर यहां पे अभी कुछ मिली है यहां पे ये
कुछ मिला है यहां पे तो यहां पे कुछ अगर
फाइल से रिलेटेड कुछ भी मिलता है तो वी
विल गेट दैट रिजल्ट नहीं मिलता है तो कोई
बात नहीं कुछ नहीं मिलेगा फिलहाल के लिए
इसको हटा देते हैं ठीक है दैट्ची
अब यह तो आपका हो गया साइट मैप एंड स्कोप
के बारे में इस पर चर्चा
होगी जो वेबसाइट होगी यहां पे स्कोप में
आप डाल सकते हैं साइट में आपने सारी
वेबसाइट लिस्ट होंगी यहां उसके कंटेंट आ
जाएंगे जो भी स्क्रोलिंग वगैरह होगी वो
यहां रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस ये सारे मैंने
बता दिया अब यहां स्कोप के बारे में बता
दिया स्कोप में ऐड कर सकते हैं रिमूव कर
सकते हैं एक्से एक्सेट अब यहां पर आते हैं
प्रॉक्सी टैब पे प्रॉक्सी टैब में यहां पे
चार ऑप्शंस है इंटरसेप्ट एसटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री वेब सॉकेट हिस्ट्री एंड ऑप्शंस
जल्दी-जल्दी इनको समझते हैं बहुत ही प्यार
से अच्छे से अब बताइए इंटरसेप्ट इसका
मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया इंटरसेप्ट ऑन और
ऑफ का मतलब है रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करना
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कीजिएगा तो जो भी रिक्वेस्ट
यहां पर आप करेंगे वह यहां पर कैप्चर होगा
देखो यहां यह कैप्चर हो रहा है रिक्वेस्ट
कहां पर जा रही है टेस्ट पीप web.com पे
कैप्चर हो रही
है हो
गया जरूरी है बट एक चीज मेरे को बड़ा यार
खराब लगा है आज कि आप लोग यार
whatsapp2 लोग आते हैं लाइव में बट वही
100 110 रह गए हम लाइव में तो यार थोड़ा
क्या दिक्कत है मतलब सोचो 1400 लोग में से
200 लोग भी लाइव नहीं आ रहे हैं
वई टाइमिंग कुछ इशू है आपके कुछ प्रॉब्लम
है बताइए मुझे आप में से सभी लोग मुझे
बताइए या क्या प्रॉब्लम है मुझे लेट मी नो
व्ट इज द
प्रॉब्लम व्ट इज द
इशू 200 लोग नहीं हो सकते क्या हम चलो इस
क्लास में नहीं हुए नेक्स्ट क्लास में हो
जाएंगे ना नेक्स्ट क्लास में तो हो सकते
हैं काली लिनिक्स के लिए भाई है है गिट पर
मिल जाएगी
आपको चलिए मुझे बताइए
ओके ओके मैं क्या करता हूं जो मैंने बोला
ना स्पैम करोगे आपको टाइम आउट में डाल
दिया जाएगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
चलिए
अ आदर्श हैज बीन टाइम आउट ड्यू टू द स्पैम
सॉरी चलिए तो यहां पे
[संगीत]
अ ओके चलिए तो यहां पे हम यहां पे
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन ऑफ करेंगे तो हम
रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करेंगे रिक्वेस्ट जो
है जो भी रिक्वेस्ट है उसको कैप्चर कर
सकते हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑन ऑफ से ड्रॉप कर
सकते हैं उस रिक्वेस्ट को फॉरवर्ड कर सकते
हैं यहां पे ये सारी चीज कर सकते हैं
इसमें भी क्या है रॉ है पैरामीटर्स है
यहां पे जो पैरामीटर है उसके बारे में
बताएगा हेडर्स के बारे में बताएगा कौन-कौन
से हेड है और यहां पे उसकी हेक्स वैल्यू
आएगी फिलहाल ये सारे आपके काम के नहीं है
रॉ वाले में आपको एक्चुअल रिक्वेस्ट जो है
वो दिखेगी या जो भी रिस्पांस है वो आपको
दिखेगी दिस इज इंटरसेप्ट ैप इसके बाद आता
है आपका ये मैं इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देता
हूं फिलहाल इसके बाद आता है आपका एचटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री ये काफी एक इंपॉर्टेंट काफी एक
अच्छी चीज है एसटीटीपी हिस्ट्री में आप वो
सारे रिक्वेस्ट को देख सकते हैं जितने
रिक्वेस्ट आपने विजिट किए हैं एक
पर्टिकुलर सेशन में तो ये सारे रिक्वेस्ट
आपको दिखा देता है एंड इसमें आप पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को सर्च आउट कर सकते हैं फिल्टर
आउट कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग तरीके की चीजें
कर सकते हैं जैसे मैंने फिल्टर पे क्लिक
किया तो यहां पे शो ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स
के रिक्वेस्ट आपको चाहिए तो इस पे आपको
टिक कर दिया अब यहां पे हाइड आइटम्स
विदाउट रिस्पांसस कोई ऐसा रिक्वेस्ट है
जिसका कोई रिस्पांस ही नहीं है तो हाइड कर
दो सो ओनली पैरामीटराइज रिक्वेस्ट ओनली
पैरामेट रिक्वेस्ट को शो करो वो भी कर
सकते हो उसके बाद यहां पे अलग-अलग और भी
चीजें लगा सकते हो यहां पोर्ट नंबर से भी
डायरेक्टली जैसे अगर आपने मल्टीपल डिवाइस
से सेटअप किए है ना बब शूट को कॉन्फ़िगर
करा है जैसे आपने एक ए डिवाइस पे भी किया
है
विंडोज पे भी किया है तो जो भी लिसन का
पोर्ट है उससे आप डिफाइन करके यहां पे लगा
के और पर्टिकुलर लिसन के उस पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को यहां फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हो
एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर में ये एक
सुविधा दी गई है चलिए मैंने यहां पे शो
ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स के रिक्वेस्ट पे
क्लिक किया अब जो इन स्कोप आइटम्स है यानी
कि de.com और टेस्ट पीएचपी सिर्फ उन्हीं
के रिक्वेस्ट को यहां पे शो किया जाएगा
बाकी और शो नहीं किए जाएंगे तो यहां पे
एटीटीपी हिस्ट्री में पूरी रिक्वेस्ट जो
है यहां पे आपको शो होती है इसमें कुछ
ऑप्शंस और भी है जो आप यूज कर सकते हैं
जैसे एक पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट है मान लो
मान लो एक पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट है ये वाली
टेस्ट पीएचपी की ये वाली एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट है इसमें मैंने राइट क्लिक किया
राइट क्लिक करूंगा तो आप एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को हाईलाइट कर सकते हो हाईलाइट
पे जाओगे तो कलराइज कर सकते हो जैसे मुझे
इसको कलर करना है इसको कलर करना है इस
वाले में तो ये पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट
कलराइज्ड हो जाएगी तो आपको पता चल जाएगा
कि ये इस रिक्वेस्ट के लिए मैंने ये कलर
यूज करा है ये काफी ज्यादा यूज़फुल होता
है जैसे मैंने अब लॉगिन वाले रिक्वेस्ट है
इसको मुझे कलराइज कर देना है हाईलाइट कर
देना है एंड मैं इसको हाईलाइट कर देता हूं
येलो टाइप से ऐसे करके तो ये एक कलराइज्ड
रिक्वेस्ट अलग से हो गया जैसे मुझे ये
वाली रिक्वेस्ट को कलराइज करनी है तो मैं
यहां पे क्लिक करता हूं राइट क्लिक करता
हूं हाईलाइट पे क्लिक करता हूं मुझे इसको
ग्रीन कर देना है तो ये ग्रीन कलर की
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो कलराइज हो गई है तो ये
सारी आप चीजें कर सकते हो फिर पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट पे कोई और भी सर्विस जैसे ये
रिक्वेस्ट है एक राइट क्लिक करते हैं ठीक
है आप इस रिक्वेस्ट को कर्ड कमांड की तरह
यूज़ कर सकते हो जो फरदर आप यूज यूज कर
सकते हो या तो आप इस रिक्वेस्ट जैसे ये
रिक्वेस्ट है तो आप इसका रिस्पांस देख
सकते हो ब्राउजर में तो राइट क्लिक करोगे
शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर इस पे क्लिक करोगे
एक यूआरएल आएगी इसको कॉपी कर लो और इसको
कहां ओपन करो भैया इसको ब्राउजर के अंदर
ओपन कर लो चलो ओपन करते हैं इसको ब्राउजर
के अंदर में ये रिक्वेस्ट जो भी रिक्वेस्ट
होगी वो यहां पे पेज ओपन होके आ जाएगी
जैसे ये de.com सर्विसेस की है तो यहां पे
ये पेज ओपन होके इस तरीके से रिक्वेस्ट
ओपन हो जाएगी ठीक है क्योंकि अभी
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन था तो यहां पे ये आप
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट जो है आप इसको ओपन
करके ब्राउजर में भी ओपन कर सकते हो यहां
पर जब आप राइट क्लिक करोगे तो यहां
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट के लिए कमेंट्स भी कर
सकते हो जैसे मुझे क्या करना है मान लो
मेरा यह एक रिक्वेस्ट है मान
लो यह टेस्ट पीएचपी की रिक्वेस्ट है मान
लो ठीक है ना इसको मुझे राइट क्लिक करना
है एंड मैं यहां पर कमेंट एक ऐड कर दूंगा
ऐड कमेंट तो यहां पे ऐड कर दूंगा कि टेस्ट
पीएचपी टेस्ट पीएचपी रिमेनिंग
रिमेनिंग
रिम रिमेनिंग ऐसे लिख देता हूं रिमेनिंग
टेस्ट यह मैंने एक कमेंट डाल दिया अब यहां
पे ओके कर दिया अब यहां पर रिमेनिंग टेस्ट
कमेंट आ गया भैया अब इसको तुम कमेंट वाइज
कमेंट वाइज ऐसे करके यह करोगे तो कमेंट
वाइज यहां पे ये फिल्टर आउट होके आ जाएगा
तो आपको पता चल जाएगा कि भैया हां ये
कमेंट किया हुआ रिक्वेस्ट है ऐसे करके आप
अलग-अलग रिक्वेस्ट पे अलग-अलग चीजें यहां
से कर सकते हो ये काफी अच्छी चीज है एक
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर जितने लिंक्स
है सबको कॉपी करना है मान लो तो आप यहां
से वो भी कर सकते हो जैसे मान लो ये टेस्ट
पीएचपी है यहां पे मैंने
किया कॉपी लिंक्स मैंने लिंक्स को कॉपी कर
लिया अब जो भी यहां पे लिंक्स होंगे जैसे
मैंने जो लिंक्स कॉपी किया मैं यहां पे
इसको हटा देता हूं मैं इसको यहां पे थोड़ा
सा बड़ा कर देता हूं ठीक है यहां थोड़ा अब
मैंने जो पेस्ट किया तो ये सारे जितने भी
लिंक्स थे ना पर्टिकुलर उस रिक्वेस्ट के
अंदर जो भी लिंक्स थे वो सारे कॉपी हो
चुके हैं तो पूरे लिंक्स आप यहां पे कॉपी
कर सकते हो गॉट इट लिंक सारे कॉपी हो गए
ये सारे काम आप कर सकते हो तो ये एचटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री का काम है एचटीटीपी हिस्ट्री से
आप ये सारी चीजें कर सकते हो बहुत अच्छी
चीज है यहां हैश पे क्लिक करोगे भैया तो
हैश पे भी जब आप क्लिक करोगे ना यहां पर
छोटा सा ऐसे तो भी यहां से आप इसको अरेंज
कर सकते हो ठीक है यहां पे हैश पे करके आप
अरेंजमेंट कर सकते हो जो भी अरेंजमेंट है
यहां पे ऊपर नीचे असेंडिंग डिसेंडिंग में
आपकी अरेंजमेंट हो जाएगी कलर वाइज भी आ
जाएगी वैसे भी आ जाएगी असेंडिंग डिसेंडिंग
के अंदर में ये हो गया उसके बाद जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट है उसका पर्टिकुलर रिस्पांस एंड
रिक्वेस्ट दोनों टैब यहां नीचे में आपको
मिल जाएंगे जब दोनों
चीजें
ठीक है अब दोनों चीजें प आओगे एंड यहां पे
यहां पर है लिनिक्स कोडर कुलदीप सर बातें
मत बनाओ कुलदीप जी आप यहां से चले जाओ
आपकी कोई जरूरत नहीं है आपकी आपको बातें
बनाने अगर आपको लग रहा है कि यहां पर
बातें बन रही है तो प्लीज मूव ऑन प्लीज गो
अहेड आपके लिए क्लास नहीं है आपके जैसे
लोगों के लिए क्लास मैं कराता भी नहीं हूं
ठीक है आपके जैसे लोग पेड कोर्सेस में
जाइए एंड वहां पर जाके सारी चीजें सीखिए
बहुत सारी चीजें है ना तो प्लीज प्लीज
प्लीज डोंट वेस्ट माय टाइम आपके लिए इतना
टाइम नहीं है वेस्ट कर कर दिया आपने इतना
अभी जो एक कुछ सेकंड हुए वो वेस्ट कर दिए
तो आपको मैं टाइम आउट पे डाल देता हूं
कितने दिन कितने टाइम के लिए 24 घंटे के
लिए थैंक यू सो मच चलिए तो यहां पे आप ये
एटीटीपी हिस्ट्री में कर सकते हैं उसके
बाद आते हैं वेब सॉकेट हिस्ट्री में अब ये
वेब सॉकेट हिस्ट्री तब आपके काम आएगी जब
आप वेब सॉकेट्स के ऊपर कुछ काम कर रहे हैं
वेब सॉकेट्स क्या होते हैं कोई भी चीज
लाइव जब आप
कुछ परफॉर्म हो रहा है कोई चीज लाइव जो
चीजें है ना वो अगर परफॉर्म हो रही है वो
वेब सॉकेट्स के अंदर आ जाएगी जैसे लाइव
चैट आप कर रहे हैं कहीं पे वो लाइव
चैट के रिक्वेस्ट को आप वेब सेट हिस्ट्री
में देख सकते हैं या फिर कोई स्टॉक
मार्केट का अगर आप स्टॉक मार्केट में
देखते हैं लाइव प्राइस चेंजिंग होती है
लाइव सारी चीजें चल रही है तो वो वेब
सॉकेट हिस्ट्री के अंदर आ जाती है वो सारी
चीजें राइट तो आप वेब सॉकेट हिस्ट्री में
वो देख सकते हैं उसके बाद आप ऑप्शंस में
आएंगे तो सेम वही चीजें है जो प्रॉक्सी
लिसन है उसकी सेटअप नीचे आप
आएंगे तो सर्टिफिकेट एक्सपोर्ट इंपोर्ट
उसके नीचे आएंगे तो क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट को
इंटरसेप्ट करने के कुछ यहां पे ऑप्शंस हैं
जैसे यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं किस टाइप की
चीजें हैं जैसे फाइल एक्सटेंशन मैच करता
है ठीक है मैच टाइप अगर फाइल एक्सटेंशन है
डज नॉट मैच अगर इससे तो किस तरह के
कंडीशंस को आपको यहां पर यूज करना है इस
तरीके से आप यहां पे इसको कंडीशंस लगा
सकते हैं ठीक है एंड ऑपरेटर ऑपरेटर्स के
साथ में यहां पे ऐड आपको करना है यहां पे
तो आपको ऑपरेटर क्या करना है मतलब
इंटरसेप्ट करने के लिए एंड या और दो आपको
ऑपरेटर मिलते हैं या या और ऐसे तो अगर
आपको या यानी दो कंडीशंस को आप मैच दोनों
में से कोई भी कंडीशन मैच हो वह आप यहां
पे एक रूल डिफाइन कर रहे हैं मैच टाइप
क्या मैच होगा भैया एक डोमेन नेम कोई मैच
हो तो या एक आईपी एड्रेस मैच हो तो एक
प्रोटोकॉल मैच हो तो एचटीटीपी मेथड मैच हो
तो यह सारी चीजें या एनी हेडर में कुछ भी
मैच हो तो यह यहां पे या फिर लिनर पोर्ट
मैच हो
तो तो यहां पे अगर आप एक कंडीशंस डिफाइन
करते हैं जैसे मान लो मैंने क्या किया एक
आईपी एड्रेस मैच कर दिया अब मैच रिलेशनशिप
क्या है इज इन रेंज या इज नॉट इन रेंज तो
इज इन रेंज करते हैं और मैं यहां पर क्या
कर दूंगा एक कोई आईपी एड्रेस मैच कंडीशन
में डाल दूंगा कि अगर इस आईपी के रेंज में
होगा तो वह चीज परफॉर्म करनी
है वह चीज होगी वह चीज अप्लाई होगी इस
तरीके से जैसे मान लो यहां पर मैं डोमेन
दे देता हूं मैच केसेस में क्या है मैचेस
अब मैं कोई पर्टिकुलर डोमेन दे देता हूं
fix.com
डेनिक्स de.com ठीक है तो ये एक मैच
कंडीशन तुम ने तैयार कर
दी तो यह रिक्वेस्ट इंटरसेप्ट कर लेगा उस
रिक्वेस्ट को पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को जो
है ना वो इंटरसेप्ट करेगा इस मैचिंग रूल
से जो भी आप मैचिंग रूल बनाओगे उस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट जैसे ही वो पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट है कहीं से भी आप करोगे जब
ब्राउज कर रहे होगे कहीं से भी मैच करेगा
तो उसको व इंटरसेप्ट करेगा ये एक इसका
फीचर है यह काफी कमाल का फीचर है आप इसको
यूज़ कर सकते हैं वैसे ही इंटरसेप्ट सर्वर
रिस्पांस के अंदर में यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं यहां देखो लिखा भी हुआ है यार यूज दिस
सेटिंग टू कंट्रोल व्हिच रिक्वेस्ट आर
इंस्टॉल्ड फॉर वीविंग एंड एडिटिंग इन द
इंटरसेप्टर तो मैचिंग के अकॉर्डिंग
इंटरसेप्ट करेगा ट्स इट खत्म गॉट
इट समझ में आ
गया चलिए उसी तरीके से इंटरसेप्ट सर्वर
रिस्पांसस में भी वैसे ही है इंटरसेप्ट
वेब सॉकेट में भी ऐसा है और यहां पे
रिस्पांस मॉडिफिकेशन इसमें कुछ चीजें हैं
जैसे कि मान लो आप कुछ चेंजेज करना जैसे
आप मानना चाहते हो रिमूव इनपुट फील्ड लेंथ
लिमिट इनपुट फील्ड की लेंथ लिमिट हटानी है
तो आप टिक कर दीजिए इसको इनेबल डिसेबल
फॉर्म फील्स अगर आपको अ इनेबल डिसेबल्ड
फॉर्म फील्स अगर कोई ऐसी आपको यह टिक करना
है तो यह क्या करेगा डिसेबल्ड फॉर्म फील्स
को इनेबल कर देगा उसके बाद यहां पे आएगा
कन्वर्ट एचटीटीपीएस टू एचटीटीपी ये भी एक
अच्छी चीज है मतलब एचटीटीपीएस को एटीटीपी
में डाउनग्रेड करने की कोशिश करेगा रिमूव
ऑल जावास्क्रिप्ट जितने भी जावास्क्रिप्ट
है सबको रिमूव कर देगा ये सारे ऑप्शंस आप
यूज कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे आता है मैच
एंड रिप्लेस यह काफी इंटरेस्टिंग काफी
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है ये आपको समझनी
चाहिए ठीक है मैच एंड रिप्लेस व्हाट इज
मैच एंड रिप्लेस अब यहां पर आप रूल डिफाइन
करेंगे क्या रूल डिफाइन करेंगे मैच करें
कहां मैच करें रिक्वेस्ट हेडर
में रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी
में रिस्पांस हेडर में रिस्पांस बॉडी में
पहली बात आपको रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिक्वेस्ट
बॉडी अगर यह नहीं पता है मैं आपको पहले उस
पर लेकर चलता हूं फिर एक छोटा सा ओवरव्यू
दे देता हूं अब
देखो यहां एक यूआरएल है कमेंड पीएपी आईडी
तो यह इसकी इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं ना
इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं कोई एक बॉडी
वाली एक रिक्वेस्ट देखता हूं कोई मिलती है
क्या
हां मैं इसको एक बार रिपीटर पर ले जाता
हूं मैं यहां दिखाता हूं जैसे यह आपको दिख
रही है ठीक है मैं इसको गो प क्लिक करता
हूं रिस्पांस आएगा अब यह जो चीज है ना
पर्टिकुलर यह रिक्वेस्ट वाले सेक्शन में
यह रिक्वेस्ट हेडर आपके कहलाएंगे
इसके बाद जो रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के बाद आपकी आ
रही है यह वाली चीज चीज अगर इधर भी रहती
ऐसा कुछ इधर भी रहता ऐसा तो यह रिक्वेस्ट
बॉडी हो
जाता उसी तरीके से यह रिस्पांस हेडर है और
ये फिर रिस्पांस बॉडी है और इनको बहुत
ज्यादा अच्छे से समझना है तो अगर आप वही
समझेंगे जो जिन्होंने उस बुक को पढ़ा है
वेब एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंडबुक उसमें बहुत
डिटेल में ये सारी चीजें बताई गई है बहुत
डिटेल में इन अ वेरी डिटेल
फॉर्मेट तो आप ये समझ जाएंगे गॉट इट सभी
को समझ में आ गया आप ये समझ जाएंगे तो ये
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर हो गई ये हो गई रिस्पांस
हेडर रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी रिस्पांस बॉडी यही
आपको यहां पर दिखाया जा रहा है किसमें यह
प्रॉक्सी वाले प्रॉक्सी वाला जो हमारा बटन
है उसके ऑप्शंस
में तो यह आप मैचिंग आप रूल डिफाइन कर
सकते हैं कि अगर रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में कोई
एक चीज मैच करती है जैसे क्या मैच कर सकती
है कुछ भी मैच कर सकती है भाई कोई
सीएसआरएफ टोकन मैच कर सकता है एक्सस का
पेलोड मैच कर स सकता
है ठीक है तो अगर मुझे रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में
कोई एक पर्टिकुलर चीज मैच कर रही है जैसे
मुझे
सीएसआरएफ इज इक्वल टू कोई एक वैल्यू है
मान लो मुझे इसको रिप्लेस करना है किससे
सी एस आरएफ इज इक्वल टू किससे रिक्वेस्ट
करना करना है 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 इससे
रिप्लेस करना है बस ये चीज करके डिफाइन हो
गई ओके कर दो जैसे ही ये रिक्वेस्ट मैच
आएगी तो ये इससे ये जो है ये मैच अगर आया
तो यह रिप्लेस किससे हो जाएगा इससे हो
जाएगा या फिर आप सारे ही चाहिए मुझे
सीएसआरएफ फील्ड में मुझे सारे ही जो भी
चीजें आए वो रिप्लेस हो जाए किससे मेरे एक
प्री डिफाइंड वैल्यू से 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
तो ये यहां से ओके करके मैच करके मैच होके
रिप्लेस हो जाएगा
दैट्ची टैब अब बात करते हैं यहां पे
स्पाइडर टैब में स्पाइडर इज वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग ये आपको वर्जन 1.7 एक में ही
मिलेगा स्पाइडर वाला ऑप्शन 2.0 से ऊपर
जाएंगे तो ये रिमूव कर दिया गया है
स्पाइडर का मतलब है पूरी वेबसाइट को क्रॉल
करना स्पाइडर करना मकड़े की जाल की तरह
जैसे मकड़े की जाल होती है ना यार एक
दूसरे से एक दूसरे से कनेक्टेड बहुत ही
पेचीदा तो ये पेचीदा लेवल का एक पूरा एक
दूसरे पूरे जितने भी वहां पे वेब पेजेस
हैं वेबसाइट के उनको स्पाइडर करता है एंड
उनको स्कैन करता है उनको स्क्रॉल करता
है जैसे मेरे पास एक टारगेट है टेस्ट
पीएपी . ववेब इसके अंदर अभी कितने
रिक्वेस्ट है इतने ही है सात अब मैं इसको
स्पाइडर करूंगा राइट क्लिक करूंगा स्पाइडर
दिस होस्ट जब मैं स्पाइडर करूंगा तो यह
कंटेंट वाला जो सेक्शन है इसपे चेंजेज
देखिएगा स्पाइडर पर क्लिक किया नाउ लेट्स
सी हियर सात रिक्वेस्ट है देखते हैं कुछ
फर्क पड़ता है कि नहीं पड़ता है सात
रिक्वेस्ट है स्पाइडर करना मैंने शुरू कर
दिया है यहां पर मैं इसको इग्नोर कर देता
हूं फॉर्म को यह देखिए रिक्वेस्ट बढ़नी
शुरू हो गई सात से आठ हो गई न हो गई यह
देखिए यह रिक्वेस्ट बढ़ रही
है यह अभी बढ़ता जाएगा इसको मैं चलो
इग्नोर मार देता हूं यह देखो इतने सारे
रिक्वेस्ट हो गए बहुत सारे रिक्वेस्ट हो
गए
ना बहुत सार रिक्वेस्ट हो गए डिस्क्रिप्शन
में इस वीडियो को देखो चैनल का लिंक मिल
जाएगा भैया नीचे जाओ नीचे जाओ चैनल का
लिंक मिलेगा डिस्क्रिप्शन
में यह देखो यहां पे इतने सारे रिक्वेस्ट
आ गए जब मैंने स्पाइडरिंग शुरू की तो यहां
स्पाइडर टाइम में आओगे तो यहां देखो
स्पाइडरिंग रन हो रही है रिक्वेस्ट जा रहे
हैं 941 950 960 कितने बाइट्स ट्रांसफर
हुए हैं रिक्वेस्ट कितने अभी क्यूड है वो
सारे रिक्वेस्ट जितने भी क्यूड रिक्वेस्ट
है वो सारे कंप्लीट हो चुके हैं यानी कि
इसकी स्पाइडरिंग कंप्लीट हो चुकी है 1084
रिक्वेस्ट भेजे गए जिसमें इतने बाइट्स
ट्रांसफर हुए हैं एंड नाउ रिक्वेस्ट इज
नाउ स्पाइडरिंग इज कंप्लीट एंड यह हमारे
पास रिजल्ट यहां पे आ चुके
हैं गट इट इतना समझ में आ गया यह
रिक्वेस्ट हमारे पास आ चुकी है
खत्म यही ये स्पाइडर में हम यही स्कैनिंग
कॉलिंग करते
हैं उसके बाद स्पाइडर में आपने ने कर लिया
देख लिया यहां ऑप्शंस में कुछ ऑप्शंस है
आप इसके लिए आपकी जरूरत नहीं है अभी
पड़ेगी स्कैनर पे आते हैं स्कैनर पे आएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको जो भी स्कैनिंग जो भी
रिजल्ट्स आपको मिल रहे हैं ना एक्टिविटीज
इशू एक्टिविटी के अंदर वो आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे जो भी इश्यूज है वो मिलेंगी स्कैन
क्यू अगर आपने कोई स्कैनिंग चालू की है वो
यहां पे दिखेगा जैसे टारगेट पे जाके आप
राइट क्लिक करोगे यहां पे एंड यहां पे आप
स्कैन करते हो एक्टिवली या पैसिवली
एक्टिवली मतलब आप टारगेट से इंटरेक्ट करके
करोगे कोई ना कोई इंटरेक्शन होगी वहां पे
पैसिवली इंट क्शन नहीं होगी फास्ट होती है
स्कैन पैसिव वाली एक्टिव थोड़ी स्लो होती
है बट ज्यादा ऑथेंटिकेट होती है ऑथेंटिक
ज्यादा ऑथेंटिक होती है तो ये आपके ऊपर है
आप एक्टिव करो या पैसिव करो फिर यहां पे
आपके स्कैन वाले में यहां पे ये शो करेगा
लाइव स्कैनिंग अगर आप कर रहे हो तो यहां
पे आप देख सकते हो इसकी कुछ सेटिंग्स है
यहां पे लाइव स्कैनिंग आप करोगे तो लाइव
स्कैनिंग भी आप कर सकते हो ये भी आप यहां
से चला सकते हो इशू डेफिनेशन में आके आपको
कुछ नहीं करना ये कुछ इश्यूज है उनके बारे
में बताया गया है जैसे एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
क्या होता है रेडिशन टेक्निक्स क्या है
कुछ रिसोर्सेस दिए गए हैं या पढ़ने के लिए
होती है ऑप्शंस में आपको फिर से कुछ ऑप्शन
मिलेंगे जिस पर ज्यादा आपको छेड़छाड़ नहीं
करनी है अब यहां पर आ जाते हैं इंट्रूडर
के ऊपर में अब इंट्रूडर काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
है भैया यह भी हम समझेंगे इंट्रूडर क्या
होता है इंट्रूडर में क्या होता है
बेसिकली गाइस जब आप कोई भी एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को इंट्रूडर के पास भेजते हो तो
एक पर्टिकुलर
पॉइंट को एक पर्टिकुलर आप रिक्वेस्ट को जब
इंट्रूडर को भेजते हो तो आप उसपे एक्शन
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो रिपीटिटिवली
मान लो यह वाली मिली मैं इसको इंट्रूडर को
भेजूंगा सेंड टू इंट्रूडर इंट्रूडर प आ
गया मैं अब यहां प यह आ गया अटैक टारगेट
ठीक है चलो चलेगा अब यहां प आते हैं
पोजीशंस पे पोजीशंस प आओगे तो यहां पर
पोजीशंस कुछ ऐड हुए हैं इसको को आप क्लियर
कर दो पहले तो अब ये पोजीशंस का मतलब है
आप किसी पर्टिकुलर वैल्यू
को आप चेंज करना चाहते हो एक अपने टारगेट
अपने अटैक के अकॉर्डिंग आप पर्टिकुलर
वैल्यू पे अलग-अलग तरह के पेलोड्स को यूज
करना चाहते हो तो आप इंट्रूडर का यूज
करो जैसे कि अब ये अटैक टाइप पहले स्नाइपर
है इसमें एक बैटरिंग रैम भी है पिच फॉक भी
है क्लस्टर बॉम भी है ये अलग-अलग टाइप के
अटैक्स हैं फिलहाल बाय डिफॉल्ट स्नाइपर को
हम यूज करते हैं अब जैसे मुझे मान लो इस
आर्टिस्ट ये जो एक यूआरएल है ये यूआरएल है
ना मान लो ये यूआरएल है मान
लो यहां पे अब मुझे क्या चाहिए कि इस वन
के जगह पे मेरे एक्सस के पेलोड्स आए मुझे
चाहिए इस वन के जगह पे आई शुड
बी पुटिंग एक्सस पेलोड ताकि इस यूआरएल पे
एक्सएसएस के पेलोड्स को एग्जीक्यूट करा
पाऊं और एक ही बार में बहुत सारे एक्सेसेस
पेट्स को मैं टेस्ट कर पाऊं तो आप इस
इंट्रूडर से कर सकते हो अब मुझे कैसे करना
है जैसे मुझे वन के जगह प चाहिए तो मैं इस
वन को ऐसे सॉरी इस वन को क्या करूंगा ऐसे
सेलेक्ट करूंगा और इसको ऐड यहां पे ऐड कर
दूंगा पेलोड मार्कर पे जो एक नया पेलोड
मार्कर ऐड कर दूंगा ऐड प क्लिक करूंगा तो
एक पेलोड मार्कर ऐड हो जाएगा वन की जगह पे
अब ये ऐड हो गया यानी इसकी जगह पे हम
पेलोड्स डाल सकते हैं पेलोड वाले ऑप्शंस
में जाके हम पेलोड वाले ऑप्श प जाएंगे अब
यहां पे पेलोड का एक सेट आपको चूज करना है
तो स्नाइपर में एक पेलोड का सेट ही आप
सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं बाकी ंग रम वगैरह में
मल्टीपल आप पे लोट्स डाल सकते हैं तो एक
यहां सिलेक्टेड है पेलो टाइप में आपको मिल
जाएंगे बहुत सारे पे लोट जैसे सिंपल लिस्ट
रन टाइम फाइल कस्टम इटरेटर कैरेक्टर्स ये
सारे पेलोड के लिस्ट मिल जाएंगे इसमें हम
अभी सब पे नहीं जाने वाले हैं जैसे-जैसे
हमें जो भी रिक्वायरमेंट होगी हम उन पेलोड
को यूज करेंगे उसको उसी समय समझेंगे अपनी
पूरी इस कोर्स में तो उसके लिए टेंशन नहीं
लेना है तो अब हम यहां पे पेलोड में जैसे
मुझे कोई अब मान लो यहां नीचे आओगे तो ये
नल पेलोड्स डाल सकते हो ब्रूट फोर्सर यूज
कर सकते हो ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए यहां जब
आप नीचे आओगे तो यहां नंबर्स भी है नंबर्स
भी डाल सकते हो तो फिलहाल हम सिंपल लिस्ट
यूज करेंगे सिंपल लिस्ट यूज करेंगे तो
यहां पे हम लिस्ट ऐड कर सकते हैं अगर आप
क्लिपबोर्ड पे कोई कॉपी है तो आप कॉपी
पेस्ट कर सकते हो जैसे मेरे पास एक्सएसएस
के पेलोड्स है चलो तो मैं क्या कर देता
हूं यहां सर्च करता हूं एक्सस पेलोड्स
यहां पे कुछ पेलोड्स मिलेंगे एक्सस के
उनको हम कॉपी करेंगे चलिए यहां पे कुछ
पेलोड्स मिल गए अब हमने इसको क्या किया
कॉपी कर लिया मान लो इतने ही पेलोड्स को
हमने कॉपी किए इतने पेलोड्स को हमने कॉपी
कर लिया अब ये कॉपी हो गया हम यहां
डायरेक्ट पेस्ट करेंगे हमारे इसमें ये
पेस्ट होके आ
जाएगा ठीक है ये पेस्ट होके आ गया अब ये
पेस्ट होके आ गया तो अब यहां पे अब हम इस
अटैक को स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं अब यानी कि
इस वन के जगह पे जो हमने मार्क किया है
पेलोड मार्कर से ये सारे पेलोड्स एक-एक
करके वहां पे आएंगे और ये हमें चेक करके
बताएगा कि यहां एक्सेसेस है या नहीं है
क्योंकि एक्सेसेस के पेलोड्स है अगर आप
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के पेलोड डालते तो वो
भी वहां पे आप डाल सकते हैं ठीक है आप कुछ
भी जो भी पे लट डालना है डाल दो वो वहां
पे काम करेगा जब आपने डाल दिया तो आप ये
देखो पे लट काउंट 42 42 पे लोट्स आपने
यहां डाले हैं रिक्वेस्ट काउंट 42
रिक्वेस्ट ये बनाएगा उसके बाद स्टार्ट
अटैक प क्लिक कर देना है एंड आपका अटैक
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा कुछ इस तरीके से आपके
अटैक जो है वो शो
करेंगे कुछ इस तरीके से देखिए अटैक आपका
परफॉर्म होगा यहां सबसे नीचे में आपको
दिखाएगा फिनिश्ड यानी फिनिश हो चुकी है
एंड यहां पर रिजल्ट दिखाएंगे रिजल्ट में
आपको यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट दिखाएगा पेलोड
दिखाए स्टेटस दिखाएगा एरर टाइम आउट लेंथ
दिखाएगा इसमें कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें यह है
एक तो रिक्वेस्ट सबसे पहला रिक्वेस्ट आपका
जीरो होगा सबसे पहला रिक्वेस्ट जीरो होगा
इसको आप कलराइज भी कर सकते हैं कलर के
अकॉर्डिंग देख सकते हैं यहां प ये कलर के
अकॉर्डिंग यहां प लिस्टेड हो चुकी है
कलराइज हो चुकी है तो आपका पहला जीरो होगा
इसके पहला जो जीरो स्टेटस आपका जो जीरो
रिक्वेस्ट होगा उसकी आपको लेंथ देखनी है
लेंथ क्या है
6468 बताइए मुझे लेंथ क्या है 6468 अब यह
जो 6468 लेंथ है यह लेंथ इससे ज्यादा बड़ी
लेंथ अगर कोई हमें रिजल्ट में मिलता है
यानी वो सक्सेसफुल होने के चांसेस है उस
अटैक के लिए वो पेलोड उस उस पेलोड का
सक्सेसफुल होना ज्यादा चांस है उसके
सक्सेसफुल होने
का अगर उसका लेंथ जीरो वाले जीरो
रिक्वेस्ट यानी पहले रिक्वेस्ट से ज्यादा
है तो चलिए इसको हम फिल्टर आउट कर देते
हैं लेंथ पर डबल क्लिक करते हैं फिल्टर
आउट करते हैं उससे बड़ा है कि नहीं कोई
कोई ऐसा कुछ बड़ा मुझे कुछ पेलोड मिला
नहीं यानी ऐसे ये पेट्स कोई काम उस
पर्टिकुलर पे नहीं करेंगे एक्सेसेस के लिए
मिलता है तो आप उस परे फिर जैसे मान लो ये
अगर बड़ा होता है एंड यहां 200 स्टेटस
होना चाहिए यानी वर्किंग है तो आप राइट
क्लिक कीजिए शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर पे
क्लिक कीजिए एंड इसको आप कॉपी कीजिए एंड
यहां पे ब्राउजर में इसको आप ओपन कीजिए
अगर एक्सेसेस ट्रिगर होगा तो यानी यहां
एक्सेसेस है नहीं तो नहीं
है गॉट इट ये सिंपल सा फंडा है ये सिंपल
सा क्या है ये सिंपल सा फंडा है यह यूज
करने का हमारा
इंट्रूडर तो यह आपको समझना है उसके आपको
फर्स्ट तीन चार पांच ऐसे जो भी लिस्ट में
यहां पे रिजल्ट्स आ रहे हैं ना उनको आपको
ट्राई आउट कर लेना है पर्टिकुलर अटैक के
लिए पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए उसी तरीके से आप
यहां पे अगर पोजीशंस प आते हैं यहां अटैक
टाइप चूज कर लेते हैं बैटरिंग रैम तो
बैटरिंग रम में आप आ जाएंगे सेम चीजें
करके पेट्स पे आएंगे तो यहां देखेंगे आप
पेलोड में आपको फिलहाल एक ही है क्यों
क्योंकि आपका एक ही आपने मार्क किया है
पोजीशन अब मैं एक और पोजीशन मार्क करता
हूं लेट्स सपोज मैंने मार्क
किया 1.1 को इसको एंड ऐड किया तो यहां
पेट्स प आएंगे तो यहां पर आपको यहां मैंने
यह मार्क कर दिया लेट्स कम टू लेट्स
रिफ्रेश इट मैं यहां पे ऑटो कर देता हूं
फिलहाल के लिए मैं यहां पे क्लियर कर देता
हूं फिलहाल के लिए सब कुछ यहां पर क्लियर
कर देता हूं ठीक है एंड यहां पर आ जाते
हैं टारगेट पे एक इसको उठाते हैं एंड इसको
कर देते हैं इंट्रूडर पे सेंड टू इंट्रूडर
पे आ जाते हैं इंट्रूडर पे आ गए ठीक है अब
यहां पे पोजीशंस पे आते हैं अब यहां
पोजीशंस पे मैं क्या करता हूं मैं एक और
पोजीशन यहां पे बना देता हूं इस वाले को
बना देता हूं मैं यहां पे ऐड कर देता हूं
एक और पोजीशन बना लेता हूं इस वाले को भी
मैं पोजीशन यहां पे ऐड कर देता हूं ठीक है
ऐड कर दिया अब मैं यहां पे एक चूज करता
हूं बैटरिंग रम यहां पे चूज किया हमने एंड
यहां पे लोट्स पे जाएंगे अब यहां पे हम
सेलेक्ट करेंगे पलट सेट एंड यहां पे सिंपल
अब यहां पे मुझे चाहिए मान लो अ लेट्स
सपोज मुझे
[संगीत]
चाहिए नंबर्स मैं यहां पे नंबर सिलेक्ट
करूंगा अब यहां पे नंबर सिलेक्ट करेंगे तो
आप नंबर्स पे ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कितने फ्रॉम
कितना फ्रॉम वन टू 1000
नंबर्स एंड स्टेप कितना एक स्टेप करना है
तो ये इतने नंबर्स को यहां पे टेस्ट करेगा
जैसे स्टार्ट अटैक करोगे तो यहां पे ये
नंबर्स को टेस्ट करना शुरू कर देगा ए
देखेंगे कि कौन से नंबर पे 200 आ रहा है
यहां पे स्टेट कोड एंड कौन सा नंबर हमारा
काम कर उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट पर्टिकुलर
अटैक के लिए य पर्टिकुलर अटैक के लिए आपको
करना
है यह पर्टिकुलर अटैक के लिए आपको करना है
और कुछ नहीं करना है यह आपको ध्यान में
रखना है तो जो भी आप अटैक परफॉर्म कर रहे
उसके लिए आप कर रहे हैं वैसे ही अगर आप
पिच फॉक के लिए करते हैं यहां पर एंड पलट
प फिर से जाते हैं तो यहां पर आपको तीनों
पेट्स जो है एक साथ मिलेंगे करने के लिए
तीनों पेलोड्स को आप एक साथ परफॉर्म कर
सकते
हैं यहां पर आपको डिफरेंट मिल गया यहां पर
डिफरेंस पिच फॉक में क्या होगा आप तीनों
पेलोड्स के लिए अलग-अलग सेट पेलोड्स के
बना सकते हैं जैसे पेलोड वन के लिए यानी
कि आपने जो पोजीशन पहला बनाया है उसके लिए
आपने मान लो सिंपल लिस्ट लगा दिया पेलोड
टू के यहां पे सिंपल लिस्ट में पेस्ट कर
दिया मान लो जो भी है यहां पेलोड टू
सेलेक्ट किया इसके लिए आपने नंबर लगा दिया
या नल पेलोड लगा दिया एंड पेलोड थ्री सेट
किया एंड इसके लिए आपने क्या लगा दिया
पेलो थ के लिए मान लो नंबर्स लगा दिए तो
सब क्याल अ अलग आप डिफाइन कर सकते हैं
अलग-अलग पेलोड्स के लिए समझ में आ
गया डि फ्रक्स अकेडमी वेबसाइट पर लॉग इन
कर कैसे करते हैं हे भगवान क्या करना है
डिफ अकेडमी पर चले जाइए सिंपल academy.com
वेबसाइट पर चले
जाइए प्रॉक्सी ऑन है क्या
भाई ऑफ
है आई थिंक डिक्स अकेडमी अभी शायद काम
नहीं कर रहा है हां इस पे आ जाइए यहां
लॉगिन पे क्लिक कर लीजिए पोर्टल पे यहां
अपना मोबाइल नंबर डालिए प्रोसीड कीजिए एंड
ओटीपी डालिए एंड लॉग इन हो जाएंगे आप
कोर्स को एक्सेस कर पाएंगे वेब पे ठीक है
चलिए तो इसको मैं फिलहाल क्लोज कर देता
हूं यहां पे है हम जहां पे थे वहां पे आ
जाते हैं बब शूट के अंदर में तो हम थे
कहां पे इंट्रूडर पे तो यहां पे आप तीनों
के लिए अलग-अलग आपने सेट कर दिया तो ये
अलग-अलग जो अटैक टाइप है उसके उस उसमें
डिफरेंसेस है और कुछ भी नहीं है बाकी सब
इंट्रोड में में सेम यही चीजें होती हैं
पर्टिकुलर आप एक पेलोड मार्कर डाल के और
उसको आप चेंजेज कर सकते हो वैसे रिपीटर
में आते हैं अब रिपीटर में आने पे गाइज ये
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है रिपीटर अब रिपीटर
में क्या करते हैं जो भी आपका रिक्वेस्ट
जो भी आपका पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल है रिक्वेस्ट
है उसको आप उसमें चेंजेज करके सामने आप
रिजल्ट्स देख के रिपीटेड रिपीटेशन वाले
काम कर सकते हैं जैसे मेरे पास एक ये
यूआरएल है एक ये पैरामीटर वाला यूआरएल है
मैं सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देता हूं अब मैं
रिपीटर पे आऊंगा तो ये मुझे सामने दिख
जाएगा ये जो भी है रिक्वेस्ट अब मैं इसको
इसका रिस्पांस देखना चाहता हूं तो ये
रिस्पांस गो प क्लिक करूंगा रिस्पांस आपको
दिख जाएगा अब ये मुझे पर्टिकुलर टास्क के
लिए करना है मुझे ये दो लिखा हुआ है डबल
क्लिक कीजिए यहां पे आप इसका नाम चेंज कर
सकते हैं जैसे इसम मैं कर देता हूं क्या
टेस्ट
पीएचपी टेस्ट पीएचपी यहां पे ये टेस्ट
पीएचपी के लिए है तो मैंने इसका नाम चेंज
कर दिया अब यह रिक्वेस्ट का रिस्पांस यहां
मिलेगा अब मुझे मान लो इसमें कुछ चेंज
करना है कुछ चेंज करना है मुझे मान लो
होस्ट को ही चेंज कर देना है मैंने यहां प
होस्ट कर दिया google.com अब मुझे का
रिस्पांस देखना है गो पे क्लिक कीजिए यहां
मुझे सामने जो रिस्पांस आएगा वो दिख जाएगा
नहीं आया तो ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं तो यह आपका रिक्वेस्ट रिपीटर जो है
यहां पे यह काम करता है मुझे कोई चीज
देखनी है वो जैसे मैं अब क्या करता हूं
मैं कंट्रोल जड करके पहले यहां आ जाता हूं
अब मुझे इस रिक्वेस्ट टाइप को चेंज करनी
है मान लो राइट क्लिक करूंगा यहां पे राइट
क्लिक एंड यहां पे क्या करूंगा चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड तो ये अभी गेट मेथड में है
गेट यह अभी क्या है गेट मेथड में देखो यही
होती है यही यही चीजें होती है जो आप
समझनी होती है एंड इसलिए मैं बहुत बेसिक
से आपको पढ़ाता हूं समझाता हूं अब देखो
अगर मैं तुम्हें पहले वेब के बारे में
थोड़ा बताने लगता तुम बोलते अरे सर क्या
बता रहे हो बग बाउंट करो बग बाउंट सिखाओ
बग बाउंट हमें चाहिए बट तुम्हें गेट के
बारे में पता है क्या गेट के बारे में मैं
गारंटी के साथ बोल सकता हूं 90 पर ऑफ यू
गाइस हियर डोंट नो अबाउट
गेट 90 पर क्यों क्योंकि आपको इंटरेस्ट
नहीं है बेसिक समझने में आपको इंटरेस्ट
नहीं है कांसेप्ट को समझने आपको इंटरेस्ट
क्या है
बग ढूंढ लो बाउंट ले लो बग ढूंढना और पैसे
कमाना बस य इंटरेस्ट लेकिन एक्चुअल चीज
कोई सीखना नहीं चाहता बड़े दुख की बात है
भाई बहुत दुख की बात है सच
में अब गेट के बारे में आप लोगों में से
मैक्सिमम लोगों को नहीं पता कैसे जानोगे
कि यहां पर मैं क्या कर रहा हूं बताओ कैसे
समझ में आएगा आपको यह बताओ मुझे लेट मी
नो कुछ लोगों को पता होगी ना यार कुछ
लोगों को पता होगी
बस
मैं तो यहां गेट के बारे में बोल रहा हूं
यह गिट के बारे में पूछ रहा है सोचो यह
राहुल जी मैं गेट बोल रहा हूं यह गिट समझ
रहा है देख लो कितना पता है
इनको या जिनको पता है एसटीडीपी मेथड्स के
बारे में गुड गुड कि आपको पता है अच्छी
बात है बट काफी लोगों को नहीं पता भाई
मेरे और ना जानना चाहते
हैं है ना गेट और गिट में अंतर है भाई यार
क्या तुम लोग पूछ रहे हो यार गेट क्या गिट
गिट गिट कर रहे हो गिट इ डिफरेंट ट गेट
गेट गेट ये गेट इज अ एसटीटीपी मेथड
एसटीटीपी मेथड होते हैं कुछ
गेट पोस्ट पुट डिलीट यह सब मेथड्स है यार
जिनके थ्रू आपका जो सर्वर या क्लाइंट है
वह इंटरेक्ट करता है एक दूसरे से एक तरीके
से इंटरेक्ट करता
है वही है यह समझे भैया तो य गट जो है अब
मुझे इसको चेंज करना है चेंज राइट क्लिक
करूंगा चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड तो यह पोस्ट
हो जाएगा पोस्ट फॉर्मेट में चेंज हो
गया अब यहां पे मैं गो करता हूं यहां पे
मुझे इस तरह का रिस्पांस मिलता है
आर्टिस्ट इसके पैरामीटर को चेंज कर सकता
हूं थ्री को फोर करके रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस
देख सकता हूं कि क्या मुझे रिस्पांस आ रहा
है अब मुझे यहां पे चेंज करना है कुछ कोई
चीज रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है कि नहीं मैं हेलो
किया यहां गो पे क्लिक किया अब यहां पे
मैं हेलो सर्च करूंगा इज इट रिफ्लेक्टिंग
नो रिफ्लेक्टिंग ऐसे करके मैं रिक्वेस्ट
रिस्पांस को देख सकता हूं उसपे फर्द
प्रोसेसिंग कर सकता हूं रिपीटर टैब में
आके यह है रिपीटर का बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
रिपीटर का हम यूज करेंगे बहुत ज्यादा ठीक
है सीक्वेंसर में आते हैं सीक्वेंसर में
क्या होता है गाइस यह पर्टिकुलर टोकेंस
को टोकेंस पर प्रोसेसेस करने के लिए
बेसिकली हम इसको यूज करते हैं सीक्वेंसर
और ज्यादा कुछ इसका यूज है नहीं बस जब हम
कोई पर्टिकुलर टोकन पे जैसे कोई पर्टिकुलर
कुकीज पर हम कोई काम कर रहे हैं या कोई
कस्टम टोकन हमें डिफाइन करना हो तो हम
सीक्वेंसर में कर सकते हैं उसको हम लाइव
कैप्चर कर सकते हैं देख सकते हैं किस
तरीके से रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है क्या
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है किस तरीके से
रिस्पांस आ रही है वो सारी चीजें ये
रिक्वेस्ट उसको भेजेगा वैसे ही उस
पर्टिकुलर टोकन का यूज
करके यह काम है आपके सीक्वेंसर
का अब ये चीजें हम देख सकते हैं वैसे तो
लाइव प्रैक्टिकल देखेंगे सीक्वेंसर का जब
आएगा ना हमारे पता है सीक्वेंसर का काम कब
आएगा जब ओटीपी फ्लड ईमेल फ्लड का हम बग
बाउंट में देखेंगे प्रैक्टिकल तो हमें
सीक्वेंसर का काम आएगा उस टाइम आपको
ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ में आएगा स्पाइडर एंड
रेकन में क्या डिफरेंस है अरे भैया
स्पाइडर एंड रेकन देखो रेकन एक पूरा मेथड
है उसके अंदर का एक पार्ट आप समझ सकते हो
रेकन एक बहुत छोटा सा पार्ट और सॉरी उसका
एक छोटा सा पार्ट आप स्पाइडरिंग समझ सकते
हो रेकन तो एक पूरा प्रोसेस है एक हरर की
एक स्टेप है एक पूरा का पूरा अपने आप में
मेथड जीी है जिसके अंदर बहुत सारे स्टेप्स
आते हैं उसमें एक स्टेप है स्पाइडर करना
क्रॉल करना गॉट
इट ठीक
है चलिए समझ में आ गया क्रॉल आप उसके अंदर
समझ सकते हैं ये आपका सीक्वेंसर है इसमें
हम करेंगे जब हम इसको प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे
तो हम इसको समझेंगे ये एक डिकोडर है जहां
पे आप पर्टिकुलर लाइव डिकोडिंग इनकोडिंग
कर सकते हो जैसे मैंने यहां पे किया
सब्सक्राइब टू डि फ्रॉक्स एकेडमी यह मैंने
टेक्स्ट लिख दिया अब मुझे इसको इनकोड करना
है तो यहां पे इनकोड एज पे आ जाएंगे मुझे
इसको बेस 64 में इनकोड कोड करना है मैं
बेस 64 करूंगा मुझे इसका बेस 64 इनकोडेड
यहां पे रिजल्ट आ जाएगा ये काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट
है अब मुझे मान लो इसको भी इनकोड करना है
फर्द मैं यहां इनकोड एज करूंगा एंड यहां
पे मुझे मान लो एचटीएमएल में इनकोड करना
है मुझे इसका एचटीएमएल इनकोडेड मिल जाएगा
अब मुझे इसको डिकोड करना है डिकोड एज
प्लेन टेक्स्ट में मुझे ये डिकोड एट प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में यहां मिला कुछ नहीं आया डिकोड
एज फिर से प्लेन ट्राई करते हैं कुछ भी
नहीं मिला क्यों अब क्यों क्योंकि यहां पे
पहले मुझे डिकोड क्या करना पड़ेगा डिकोड
एज बेस 64 यह मैं करके देखता हूं ये यहां
पे बेस 64 में इस तरीके से डिकोड होके आ
रहा है यहां पे मुझे अब मुझे मान लो
स्मार्ट डिकोड करना है मैं स्मार्ट डिकोड
करूंगा तो मुझे स्मार्ट डिकोड करके जैसे
हीे मेरा जो बेस 64 वाला डिकोडिंग जो ऊपर
में इनकोड हुआ था वो इनकोडिंग यहां पे
मुझे बेस 64 वाली मिल जाएगी अब मुझे अगर
यहां पे डिकोड करना है डिकोड करके यहां पे
अगर मैं प्लेन कर दूंगा तो नीचे यहां पे
ये प्लेन ही आएगा बट अगर मुझे इसको नॉर्मल
जैसे यह मैंने बेस 64 में कर दिया अब मैं
यहां पे अगर इसको करता हूं ऑक्टेल में तो
मुझे इसका ऑक्टेल डिकोडिंग आ जाएगा मुझे
अगर डिकोड में आ करके मैं बाइनरी में करना
चाहता हूं तो मुझे यहां पे बाइनरी में
डिकोडिंग फिलहाल क्योंकि क्योंकि यार
बेसिकली यहां पे इनकोडिंग होगी ना आपकी तो
ये डिकोड मैं कर रहा हूं यहां पे मैं
स्मार्ट डिकोड अगर करता हूं तो यहां पे जब
आप नीचे आओगे यहां स्मार्ट डिकोड किया
मैंने सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी यहां मैंने
स्मार्ट डिकोड किया तो यहां पे ये
स्मार्टली जो भी आपको डिकोड करके देना
चाहेगा ये आपको डिकोड करके दे देता है तो
आप एक ही स्क्रीन में सामने इनकोडिंग
कोडिंग सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं ये इसका
फायदा है बस टेक्स्ट को यहां पे आपको हेस
वैल्यू को भी करने का ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा ये
इसके फीचर है अब जैसे मुझे जैसे मैं क्या
करता हूं नीचे आ जाता हूं नीचे आ जाता हूं
भैया नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ
ठीक है नीचे आ जाओ चलो ये आ गया अब मुझे
यहां पे मान लो इसको इनकोड करना है किस
फॉर्मेट में बाइनरी में तो मैंने यहां पे
किया यहां पे एंड दिस वन विल बिकम लेट्स
इनकोड इट ये इस तरीके से बाइनरी इनकोडिंग
यहां पे आप देख सकते हो न 11 10 10 इस
तरीके से करके बाइनरी इनकोडेड होके ये
इनकोडेड फॉर्मेट में आ गया तो इनकोडिंग
डिकोडिंग वाला काम आप यहां से कर सकते हो
ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे कंपेरर है यहां पे आप
क्या कर सकते हैं टू डिफरेंट डाटा को
कंपेयर कर सकते हैं ये हमारे अभी काम का
कोई नहीं आने वाला है जब हम एडवांस लेवल
पे थोड़ा जाएंगे जब हम डटा को कंपेयर करने
की कोशिश करेंगे तो ये उस टाइम काम आएगा
उस टाइम हम प्रैक्टिकली समझेंगे तो ज्यादा
शायद आपको समझ में आएगा उसके बाद आते हैं
एक्सटेंडर पे अब एक्सटेंडर बहुत ज्यादा
यूज नहीं आने वाला है आपके यहां पे
एक्सटेंशंस को आप ऐड वगैरह कर सकते हो ठीक
है कोई थर्ड पार्टी कोड वगैरह है वो आप
डाल सकते हो यहां पे इसके कुछ एक्सटेंशंस
की रिपोजिटरी हैं बी ए स्ट बब शूट का अपना
एक्सटेंशन रिपोजिटरी आप इसमें आके
एक्सटेंशंस को इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं कुछ
एक्सटेंशंस काम के आपके होंगे कुछ आपके
बहुत सारे इसके काम के हैं बिना काम के
हैं बट कुछ सारे हैं जो वो काफी काम के
एक्सटेंशंस हैं हम थ्रू आउट बग बाउंट
जर्नी कुछ एक्सटेंशंस का भी यूज करेंगे
बाब शूट के अंदर तो आप यहां से डायरेक्टली
इसको यहां से करके एंड उसको डाउनलोड करके
आप इसको यहां पे कन्फर फर करके इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हो जैसे आप यहां देख सकते हो राइट
क्लिक यहां पे करोगे क्लिक यहां पे
इंस्टॉल करके एंड फिर यहां पे ऊपर में टैब
में वो आ जाएगा एक्सटेंशन आप उसको यूज कर
सकते हैं प्रोजेक्ट ऑप्शंस में यहां पे
कुछ ऑप्शंस है जो काम के नहीं है यहां पे
ऐसे नॉर्मल सी सेटिंग्स वगैरह है एटीटीपी
के रिलेटेड ए सेल्स रिलेटेड ये सारी है
यूजर ऑप्शंस में यूजर के सेटिंग्स वगैरह
हैं एंड यहां पे अलर्ट्स में है यहां पे
कुछ अगर अलर्ट वगैरह आता है तो ये अलर्ट
आपको यहां पे शो करेगा ये पूरी की पूरी
आपकी बॉब शूट की ये एक थोरो वॉक थ्रू हो
गई एक तरह से जहां पे आपको हर एक चीज बब
शूट का आपको मैंने बता दिया है हर एक चीज
आपको समझा दिया है ठीक है हर एक चीज मैंने
आपको बता दिया अब मुझे ये बताओ मुझे मतलब
एकदम चलो देखो कुछ एकदम ईमानदारी से मुझे
बताओ कि अगर आपको बग बाउंट जर्नी में बब
शूट को यूज अब करना होगा आगे क्लासेस में
तो आपको कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं आएगी समझने
में कि भैया ये स्कैनर क्या है स्पाइडर
क्या है प्रॉक्सी क्या है रिपीटर क्या है
सीक्वेंसर क्या है इंट्रूडर क्या है ये तो
समझ में आने में कोई दिक्कत नहीं आएगी ना
मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी चैट में में जल्दी
बताइए फिर मैं आगे बढ़ता हूं फटाफट लेट मी
नो
फास्ट कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं आएगी
जल्दी फटाफट बता
दीजिए समझ में आ गया सबको एवरीवन गॉट एक
थोरो आपका जो वक थ्रू है हो
गया एक्टिवेशन की वीडियो मैं
आपको इसी वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइए
नीचे स्क्रॉल कीजिएगा थोड़ा
ये इसको फॉरवर्ड करोगे तो नेक्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट पर जाता है बस जो भी नेक्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट होगी उस पर चला जाएगा बस जब जो
जो एक एक रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करना है तो
यह फॉरवर्ड बटन क्लिक कर कर के एक एक
रिक्वेस्ट आएगी उसको पढ़िए उसको समझिए यह
सारी चीज आप कर सकते हो फॉरवर्ड से ठीक है
एवरीवन गट सबको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया
भैया चलिए आई होप आप सबको समझ में आ गया
होगा क्लास अच्छी लगी आज
की फॉरवर्ड होगा इंटरसेप्ट ऑन रहना चाहिए
एंड आपका नेटवर्क सही से काम करना चाहिए
बब शूट की एक्टिवेशन सही से होके और आपका
सर्टिफिकेट अच्छे से कॉन्फिन होना चाहिए
सब
होगा यह हमारे सोशल हैंडल्स है आप इस परे
हमसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं यह हमारा एक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी का मास्टरी कोर्स है
बिगनर टू प्रो लेवल का जहां पे बग बाउटी
भी इंक्लूडेड है जो कि आप f.com साब
सिक्योरिटी मास्ट कोर्स यूआरएल पे जाएंगे
तो या फिर ं इस यरल पे जाके आपको डिटेल्स
सारे चेक आउट कर सकते हैं एंड इनरोल कर
सकते हैं एंड
दैट्ची तो ये बता ही दिया है आपको डिफ
अकेडमी पप इंस्टॉल कर लेना है वहां जाके
आपको फ्री कोर्स में इनरोल कर लेना है
जवाइन कर लेना है क्योंकि जो भी रिसोर्सेस
है वही मिलेंगी आपको एंड
तो आई होप आपको सेशन अच्छा लगा होगा एंड
काफी मजा आया आप लोग इतने लोग आए यहां पे
सभी जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक के जाना भाई लाइक
ठोक के 137 लाइक्स हैं अभी 150 प्लस करके
जाना ठीक है तो आई होप आपको मजा आया होगा
आज के सेशन में एंड ऐसे ही और भी बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग अभी तो बहुत सारी चीजें बाकी
है यार अभी तो रेकन स्टार्ट ही नहीं हुआ
रिकन के पहले की चीजें चल रही है रेकन में
तो मजे आने वाले हैं अलग-अलग तरीके से पता
नहीं क्या रकन होगा सब डोमेन ओमेन
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग पता नहीं डायरेक्ट ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग सब करेंगे तो ये सारी चीजें
स्टार्ट होने वाली सारी चीजें करने वाली
है ट्राई हैक मी सबको लॉगइन कर लेना है
यूआरएल वहां पे प्रैक्टिस करनी है आपको
ट्राई हैक मी याद रखिएगा ट्राई हैक मी
नहीं तो कुछ भी नहीं ट्राई हैक मी को आपको
लेके चलना है ओस टॉप 10 वाली जो लैब है
उसको सॉल्व कर लेना है पूरी की पूरी सबकी
ल लैब आई होप सो सॉल्व हो चुकी होगी तो
चलिए तो आज के सेशन को यही एंड करते हैं
139 लाइक्स ही हैं बट कोई बात नहीं अगर आप
लोग नहीं भी करेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
150 प्लस मैंने सोचा था हो जाएगा आपके
जाते-जाते ब ठीक है चलिए तो इस सेशन को इस
वीडियो को इस लाइव स्ट्रीम को अपने
दोस्तों के भी शेयर कीजिए और
बैक करूंगा वापस से आपको रिस्पॉन्ड करूंगा
तो थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग दिस अमेजिंग
सेशन थैंक यू सो मच गाइ सब के सब फिर से
नेक्स्ट सेशन में जरूर आना एक दिन का गैप
रहेगा हर सेशन में ये बात मैंने पहले ही
बोल दिया है यानी कि आज सेशन हुई है बग
बाउटी की तो कल नहीं होगी तो जो सेशन गैप
मिल रहा है उसमें आपको छोड़ने नहीं देना
जो भी बताया गया उसको प्रैक्टिस करनी है
बब शूट के बारे में थोड़ा देखिए समझिए और
भी एक्सप्लोर कीजिए और बाकी चीजें जो है
आप डिफन एडमी
पूछते हैं कि सर हमें साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
रोड मैप नहीं पता साइबर सिक्योरिटी के रोड
मैप की वीडियो डालो भैया ऑलरेडी डली हुई
है कितना डालो यह तो बताओ कितनी आपको रोड
मैप बताऊं यहां पे आप डेनिक्स की आप चैनल
को ओपन करो यहां वीडियो सेक्शन में जाओ
यहां वीडियो सेक्शन में नीचे आओगे सबसे
नीचे नीचे आते जाओ नीचे आते जाओ नीचे आ
नीचे आते जाओ तो दूसरा वीडियो एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का रोडमैप का छोटा सा वीडियो
है इसको देख लीजिए और उसके बाद यहां पे
बिकम साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल करियर
रोडमैप ये दो घंटे की ऑलमोस्ट वीडियो है
आप इसको देख लीजिए बहुत सारी चीजें आपको
समझ में आएंगी रोड मैप को लेके साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर में काली इंस्टॉलेशन
की वीडियो देख लीजिए काली इंस्टॉल नहीं
किया तो ठीक है डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक ये वीडियो
जरूर देखिए डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक की डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक की कंप्लीट 4 घंटे की फ्री कोर्स
है इसको देखिए क्योंकि हम लेकर आ रहे हैं
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक का एक लाइव ट्रेनिंग बैच
एक ऐसे अफोर्डेबल फी पे एक ऐसे अफोर्डेबल
प्राइस पे जिसको आपने इमेजिन नहीं करा
होगा इंटरनेट पे पूरा छान मारोगे ना उस
प्राइस में आपको डिस्ट फंसी कोई नहीं
कराएगा इस गारंटी क्योंकि हम मोटिव विजन
साथ लेके चलते हैं मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल और
फ्री एजुकेशन तो मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल के अंदर
उसको लेकर आ रहे हैं एंड वो अनाउंसमेंट
सेकंड जनवरी को आपको मिल जाएगी तो डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक वाले अनाउंसमेंट के लिए रेडी
रहिएगा आप लोग क्योंकि काफी लोग डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक के लिए बोल रहे थे सर बैच लाओ सर
उसकी क्लासेस लाओ ये वो तो एक कंप्लीट
कोर्स आपके लिए लेकर आ रहे हैं पूरी फुल
बेसिक से एडवांस कोर्स उसको करने के बाद
आप बहुत सारे सर्टिफिकेट सर्टिफिकेशन जो
है फॉरेंसिक की उसको भी क्रैक कर पाओगे
गारंटी चलिए तो आज के लिए बस इतना ही एंड
मिलते हैं गाइज नेक्स्ट क्लास में नेक्स्ट
क्लास कब है अरे भाई नेक्स्ट क्लास कब है
एंड आज की आपकी नाइट अच्छी रहे एंड हैव अ
गुड नाइट सी यू एंड वी विल मीट इन द
नेक्स्ट सेशन थैंक यू सो मच गाइस टाटा बाय
बाय बिल्कुल कर सकते हो बि